And we're live.
We're live.
There's
Eddie Bravo,
Brian Cowen,
Brendan Schaub,
Eddie Bravo.
The man introduced me to marijuana for him.
I will forever be grateful for medical reasons.
Medical reasons,
medical reasons.
Yeah,
totally illegal.
Now we don't even know
what is it that goes into effect?
It's now,
it was midnight that night.
What's legal?
Marijuana recreationally legal.
Wow.
You got to be 18 or 21 I think you have to be 21 but now with attorney general
Jeff sessions,
if he gets confirmed,
can he override the federal powers do not painted.
He would go against the will of Trump.
And I think the Trump for all of his faults that you might find in him,
he's a populist.
The,
I think the best argument is that a guy like him,
you can sort of influence him with the,
the opinion of the country,
you know?
And so it's kind of an interesting thing because it might be one of the first
times ever,
like the,
the opinion of the country might significantly influenced some guy who's just
completely foreign to the idea of politics.
It's kind of a good thing.
Yeah.
Like many things in life,
very practical.
This is not perfect.
Nothing's perfect like many things in life,
but it might ultimately be a good thing to completely shake up the system.
The thing that troubles people that oppose that idea is all the Wall Street guys
he's bringing in like right away he's bringing in all these billionaires and
Goldman Sachs.
He's bringing a lot of business people to practical as well,
so who understand the economy will sit and wait,
listen,
it might be good.
That might be a good thing and you might,
that might be what they need to honestly figure out the economy and isn't a,
I mean I'm not saying it's impossible,
I'm not saying it's definite,
but isn't it possible that you could be a billionaire and still want to fix the
fucked up?
Especially if you have everything you've ever wanted.
And a lot of these guys,
they do operate on that,
that you know,
infinite growth idea,
like to constantly want to give bigger yards,
bigger match.
It's bigger houses,
but it's also possible that God could be just an intelligent guy that did really
well in business.
Like even some of the things Trump said himself.
He said,
yeah,
I took advantage of these loopholes,
but let's get rid of him.
He shouldn't think about what he did for a long time,
which was he was at,
he owned what hotels,
buildings and wanted to give you the best experience possible.
A guy like that who has,
he has a massive ego of course is it's going to do,
he wants a legacy he can point to.
He wants to go down as the greatest presidents who wants to fix the fix these
problems.
I can see that.
Hope my worry.
That's where his ego's my worry is that a guy like that is used to getting his
way all the time.
That did.
The nature of the presidency is one in which you don't get your way,
where you have to compromise what you've got to like.
A lot of times you get very frustrated with the power.
You don't have
a lot though in business like he's filed for chapter 11 multiple times,
like he's had a lot of failures as as all business,
most successful people have.
I'm just saying,
I wonder when,
what's
going to happen when he can't convince companies to do his bidding,
when a lot of his policies maybe don't give his voter base the jobs they wanted
because he can't implement the policies he wants.
That's when it's going to be interested.
Do you think we'll see an assassination attempt?
Jesus crushed printed Shab what?
Man?
I don't think it's going to happen.
I don't think so.
It was a crazy,
I don't tell me people are upset.
It's possible.
There are a lot of people that's always pasta.
What kind of people?
People have tried to kill the president many times.
Most of America,
Hillary won the popular vote.
Actually currently it by what?
55 500,000 but the crazy thing about the debate between Hillary and Trump,
Trump's done some debug things or whatever,
but when he goes,
you guys know what pizza gate is about.
Oh,
are you familiar with it?
Pizza Gate?
Yes.
No,
no.
Yes,
yes,
I do.
But I never heard of him.
He's explained to me and I said,
I'm going to explain it.
I'm not going to get to it,
but I'm just [inaudible] shit.
Eddie,
Eddie.
Before you go into it,
it's been debunked.
It's the biggest bunch of bullshit.
Oh my God,
it's fake news.
They felt moved his fake news.
It's the fee.
So the debit credit for the power,
the power structure and the Democratic Party are pedophiles and they all
communicate with each other with those secret paddles.
Is this where we're going to going to hop off Ebay?
It was proven to be a horse shit story.
If you buy into it,
the joke is on you.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you how.
Wow.
I'm telling you what.
That's very unbelievable.
It's incredible.
So,
so what does the,
so,
so are you saying,
what are you saying that the power structure,
no one files.
This is what I'm saying.
Come on.
This is what I'm,
this is really like,
but hold on a second.
This is what I'm saying.
This is what I'm saying is it's so fucking dark.
All the Shit Alex Jones has been saying.
He's been saying all that Pizza Gate Shit for 20 years.
He's been saying.
Everyone thought he was.
No,
you couldn't believe anything he said because of the things he's saying now when
you look at pizza gate,
all that shit he was saying that everyone thought he was crazy for cause.
Shit's real now.
The fake news story,
Eddie.
Dude,
it's a new story.
Every newspaper,
every,
every credible news organizations bullshit.
Then like,
I don't know,
she just posted more than you are today.
Economist.
Take both sides.
Take the right and the left.
It's a lot.
It's a joke.
It was a Joe [inaudible] is.
Wow.
So any power structure.
You didn't get the joke eddy,
the power structure.
All pedophiles.
What are you talking about?
Hey,
what are you talking about?
That's what I'm talking about and love.
So,
so the power structure,
ours.
Brian,
have you seen the documentary conspiracy of silence?
Have you seen that?
Sure haven't buddy.
You still,
of course you're having,
I don't cause I don't get my news from Youtube.
I get my news from,
from see what angle?
Both credible news organizations show top independent lines of inquiry.
Hey Joe,
can you do me a favor?
I'm outside looking in.
What
is pizza gate is,
there's a guy who worked for Hillary Clinton's campaign and his name is Podesta.
Right?
John Podesta.
That's his name.
There's a this some pizza restaurant in.
Is it in DC?
I'll leave it to Washington.
It's in Comet Ping Pong and Besta Pizza and apparently they have art that's like
this kind of famous pedophile like Pat Art,
which is close to the man love is that finishes.
What about those paintings?
There was no,
no,
no.
He's just,
he's not saying,
he's just saying it's just also with some hands on what it would do.
But Brian,
what are the paintings that they're being accused of having love?
No,
but not that.
Not the symbol.
There's,
there's some paintings that were connected to,
do you know what I'm talking about?
There was some like very bizarre.
It disturbed the shit out of me so much.
I said,
I don't want to spend any time looking at this.
You know what?
I know for sure though,
for sure.
100% that speaker of the House Guy,
Dennis Hastert.
Yeah,
they've got put away for like 15 months for being an admitted child molester.
That's right.
The idea that you could only get in the idea that this guy was the speaker of
the house.
Yikes.
He was the speaker of the house and he was fucking kids when he was a wrestling
coach and eating pizza and now this is a different guy.
Well that was stabbed.
I don't do it.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know if it was because he's old and he's very sick and ill,
but it means nothing to me.
The idea that you could take,
get a admitted kit fucker and you only give him 15 months.
That's shit.
There's more to the story.
I'm sure there is.
I'm sure there is more of the story,
but the facts remain that that guy got a very short sentence end was the speaker
of the house and it was like a child molester.
Really?
100% was normal.
Yeah.
But there are always going to be pedophiles now,
but instead of having this like gigantic blanket attitude that what he's saying
is ridiculous and then getting super emotional about it.
Let's just look at the actual fact that a guy who was a pedophile was the
speaker of the House has nothing to do with this store.
You're right,
it doesn't.
But to mock the idea that people were pedophiles can't get the high positions of
power was exactly what you were doing.
It's not an old one.
It's where are you getting real emotional?
Cause I was getting emotional because this story was proven through many
independent lines of inquiry I believe to be,
to be literally a hoax.
And when you give it a voice,
when it's a hoax and you know these people look at it way closer to anybody at
this table and it's not about the conspiracies to here.
What I'm trying to do is,
I'm trying to say guys,
guys,
hold on.
This was,
this was kind of a,
this was a big hoax and so many different people who looked at who,
I don't have it,
they don't have an agenda.
They looked into it and I'm like,
Whoa,
what's going on?
It's a fake story,
but one of those fake science.
Yeah.
Just makes sense.
Do we really want to spend time on fake Remy?
Let's talk about real stories.
Let me establish where I am.
I know the very brief outline of what it's all about.
I know that a lot of people think are pedophiles and crazy and Satan worshipers
and there was that some spirit cooking thing,
some bizarre thing that was a released in an email about something that Podesta
was going to get into.
True,
right?
Yeah,
that's true,
but it's like some bizarre,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's weird.
It's not,
I don't know if we've not even knows.
All that won't speak up over here.
Looked into it deeply and I,
I'll conspiracy theories make sense to me now.
I get it.
Every single one.
Sorry.
That's annoying.
Kind of.
I can a guy speak in general terms without being checked every got damn time.
Yes.
Yes,
of course.
It's general.
When it got dead,
he beat him every God damn time.
I would say damn time,
but 90% of the time do you know who you're explaining this shit any would you
admit?
And speaking in general terms,
what do I got to give you actual numbers.
But Eddie would you admit it?
You admit that human beings,
you me,
all of us tend to get a feeling and then we have what's called confirmation
bias,
which is we'll find,
we'll find we all,
we all do it.
I do it,
we'll do it.
We'll find,
we'll find facts to support our feeling.
That's so human.
Listen,
all you have to do is hear an argument between me and my wife and I'll fucking
justify it any way I can.
Cause I find facts to get until the Highland on,
on my side.
Yeah.
So let's all be careful about confirmation bias.
I mean all I'm saying is like to just to get super emotional and say it's
impossible.
Like I don't necessarily think it is impossible.
If that speaker of the house guy was in place,
this story particularly in particular pizza gate,
you just got to love them.
I know zero about story,
but let me,
let me,
that's what I'm from where I am.
I looked into it very little.
I saw it was,
I'm like,
I'm going to just let this scuffle go on and then look into it when the dust
settles and a couple of weeks and that scared that figure out exactly what it
does,
whether it's bullshit or real.
It made me,
me looking into it made me want to shut the fuck up about conspiracy theories
because people,
people,
people get killed when you actually look into it and I'm like Brian,
count when you actually look into it.
Yeah.
With LP to fucking mind.
Yes.
Shim it.
Brian.
I trust.
I don't trust you need a politician.
That shit.
All I'm saying truth is somewhere in the middle.
You know?
I think everybody picks a position and I bet it's probably not nearly as fucked
up as everybody's making it out to be,
but there's some weird,
first of all,
that Podesta Guy,
I was like really?
In the UFO shows too.
There's smoke,
there's fire guys,
guys,
guys.
No,
I'm sorry.
It hasn't stopped,
isn't pedestrian.
Hold on.
I don't believe so.
Wait a minute.
Hold on.
I care about that.
And you just storm troops over there in the middle of what I'm saying is I'm
reacting to what I had read from credible sources as we wish.
You can cite what it says she
was.
Okay.
Okay,
cool.
My phone,
pull it up just to,
well,
just give it to Jamie.
I'll throw it up on one of the big screen and then we'll knock this out.
Yep.
All I got to say is,
I don't even want to get into it,
but all you need to do is go to youtube and watch the conspiracy of silence.
It's a documentary.
How long has it was supposed to be on the BBC,
but they never aired it.
Who made it?
Uh,
your mother Kalin?
No Hood.
Who made it important?
No,
it's not.
It's not.
No.
Disney made it.
I've,
I've done don't you believe to have Disney made it?
What the Hell is pizzagate?
Here it is,
Jamie.
I'm going to give this to you.
Hold on.
Hold.
Please tell him.
Just tell him what it is and he'll get it online.
Here's a computer as well.
It's interesting because the two,
you guys are so on the opposite end of the holes and conspiracy thing.
Complete Ahmoud tend to immediately go towards conspiracies.
He tends to immediately go towards the mainstream [inaudible].
Those guys guys want someone to convince me.
It's not that what it is is I tend to not trust shit.
They say he tends to trust everything they say.
Mr. Scenario,
that's not a fair characterization.
On the macro story side,
dude,
you're one of those guys.
I read
Washington Post
New York Times,
Washington,
the second oldest magazine in the world.
You read all of them.
Do you remember the Bulls?
Do you know how those editorial boards,
you study the bullshit he do.
You know how those editorial boards work?
Do you know you?
Do you really think that the entire editorial board of the New York Times or the
wall or the economist or the Wall Street Journal where people who run the
country in the world get their information?
Do you think all those people are lying game together and being conspiratorial
to give us fake news and for what?
Is that really what you believe?
That's exactly it.
It's been proven.
They spent $500 million.
It's Eddie put up two books that I do believe.
So everything that the New York Times,
The Wall Street Journal,
the Economist reports,
not everything.
And what the,
just the agenda.
Just getting me a gen y.
There's an agenda.
21 is,
I don't Eddie,
but I want you to tell me,
you know what the new world order is.
I don't,
but do you know,
of course you don't because you think people are controlling everything like the
world economy or the oil markets.
How'd you know how oil is priced?
Do you know how oil is priced?
Huh?
Okay.
It's,
it's an open market commodity.
It's a world commodity,
right?
So it really depends on how much is available in that given day.
So exam,
for an example,
you may have an oil tanker that it's on its way to a country and then somebody
on the market in the market place bids on that oil and wants that oil and that
ship will turn back around and go to that market.
It all depends on what the marketplace and what all the different players who
need oil and the amount of oil that's available,
whether it's crude or raw,
whatever it might be.
It,
there's so many different factors that go into pricing oil.
Look at what happened,
look at what happened when we came up with ways to shale to to get the the oil
out of the Shales Sands,
right?
Well what happened?
The price of oil went down because the United States became an exporter of oil.
There was such,
there was an oil glut and that's why Russia is having a major problem because
they're oil used to be $100 a barrel,
what is it,
$47 a barrel or something.
So what I'm saying is that that's how oil is priced.
That's helped design.
You're talking about,
I know this,
if an organism called the world economy called the u s economy,
where there are so many different moving parts and so many different competing
interests.
So the,
say that one group of seven men or whoever they might be or 21 men controls
things is holding the strings is Hollywood movie stuff.
It would be impossible.
It's hard to control anything.
Even in Washington,
it's such a chaos fuck job.
So when you are so far on the other Goddamn side,
there's an unknown.
The dudes in the middle there somewhere we'll rolling.
It's not possible,
but I mean people have influenced people like the people that run the World
Bank,
people that have massive influence over just enormous sums of money.
Don't you think it's possible they can have some influence due to the
relationships with the shrine?
They all try and they try to have some [inaudible] at the top,
but he knows what's going on.
What I'm saying is that it,
again,
they're,
they're competing with each other.
There's so many different competing.
Right.
I mean that's the issue.
The World Bank is a massive bureaucracy.
Uh,
the IMF has a massive bureaucracy.
No,
I couldn't,
I completely understand.
I think there,
there has to be some sort of control and manipulation involved.
Well,
let me give you an example.
So let's say let's take the,
let's take the,
let's take the division.
Uh,
let's take the Latin American Bank,
which is,
uh,
I think it's a subsidiary of the World Bank,
I believe.
And I sat next to this guy on the plane and talked to him and he said that so
much of them,
the sort of projects and the money,
what they were there for was to essentially invest,
uh,
give investments.
I'm sorry,
give money to investments in the Latin American economy,
uh,
to build up the Latin American economy in one way or another.
And I'm generalizing,
what happens sometimes is that that bank no longer becomes necessary because the
economy of Latin America,
whatever that country is,
is running on its own.
So now here's a conspiracy for you,
which makes sense.
They go,
but now they go,
they go,
well we got 3,500 people who are working at the bank,
the Latin American Bank.
If there's nothing,
if there's nothing left for them to do,
we've got to come up with something that for them to do and they might,
they now they have a vested interest in staying in business because he had 3,500
people whose jobs are at stake now.
You can come up with projects that are fake or you'll like,
you guys still need us,
you know,
because we should do this and that.
That makes sense.
That would be,
if you want to call that conspiracy theory,
I would call that people who are just want to hold onto their jobs.
And do you come up with reasons to exist?
Do you know what operation mockingbird is?
Cool.
She doesn't.
Of course she don't.
I don't buy
because if you did you wouldn't be saying all that shit that,
did you hear what I said?
Did I say anything that has any real idea?
What the fuck you said?
I wasn't listening to shit knows.
Got a good top game here.
So good fight to the operation.
Mockingbird.
You're strong.
Where can I look that up?
Anywhere?
The library but can I,
the fibers are not real Burberry mockingbird.
So it up to him.
Why?
Why do you believe she,
we know.
What operation do you believe in all these conspiracy theories like operation
mockingbird.
Do you believe documentary on Youtube over the economist?
Why would you believe?
And you don't even know who made it,
but you believe in a documentary versus talking about some shit you've never
seen.
Just because it's on youtube.
It's like it's not real.
It's on youtube.
You don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about about this documentary that
you believe that document.
You don't even know what it is you believe that has really no.
I'm asking you why you were being seen it.
Why do you believe and I think people talk.
There's evidence.
I see the evidence.
I don't read about it.
I see him stepping in as you both have your friends.
We've gotten so crazy here that you guys are arguing and we haven't even
discussed what this movie's about.
Like it hasn't even been whether or not it is a operation mockingbird,
whether it was a conspiracy theory or whether it was a real event.
We didn't even discuss what it is and you guys are at each other's throats.
It's kind of crazy.
I mean we didn't,
Louie literally didn't even bring up what the subject is.
And Brian,
you jumped on him?
Uh,
no,
no I did not jump box.
Just me sir.
Excuse me sir.
You did.
Because the seat's may really started talking about,
well look,
you can't say it's a real thing cause the Wikipedia,
it's on the Internet.
Sorry,
you brought a pizza gate.
Fucking
no,
he brought up,
there's no way I was saying please.
I just want to know what pizza gate.
The fucking shit.
I want to talk about it and I don't want to talk.
He's the guilty and I don't mean
no.
Look at him.
He's the one who shared her pizza.
I was fucking interested then you should bring it up.
Yeah,
you son of a bitch.
You son of a bitch.
You through kindling talk before he thought,
why don't I think Eddie brought it up the whole time.
I'm like,
shut.
That sounds interesting.
You had me at pizza gate.
I wanted to know what it was,
but I just wanted to say,
because a lot of people on the Internet want me to bring that shit up and I'm
like,
I really don't want to bring it up.
That's some scary shit when you really look into it.
Shit that you've never done when you actually,
we actually look into it doesn't even know
operation mockingbird is a CIA operation where they were to prevent
and control communism infiltration.
They thought it would be best to buy up as many different uh,
um,
a broadcasting companies and they wanted to own the media.
They wanted to magazines,
newspapers,
CNN is part of that shit.
Anderson Cooper is admitted a CIA agent.
He admits it.
He goes,
yeah,
it was in the CIA.
So what
he actually worked for them like when he was in college.
Is that what it was?
It did when you're in your internship or something like that to go to the CIA
college to be a CIA agent?
No,
no,
no.
They make random internationally.
CIA and it's,
Uber is not a CIA agent.
He could look into it.
Guys looking for the CIA.
CIA had had to do some operation mockingbird.
We're going to control the media.
You buy into the media.
That's why you don't know about operation mockingbird.
You've been caught
in the media.
They do.
They got you strong song a long time ago.
Metro pro vaccine,
right?
Ah,
yes.
You're anti vaccine all the,
all the way across.
Okay.
Have you not,
not where for smallpox to theory and measles and all the things and mumps
seems aren't the same.
So when you talk about vaccines,
they're not all the same.
True.
Some,
uh,
can be safe and some can be dangerous school.
That's true.
I can,
I can understand.
That's all I'm going to say about that.
That's a reasonable thing with any of that.
Many doctors agree on that.
Yeah.
You know what happened in 1986 Ronald Reagan signed a bill that made big Pharma
immune to lawsuits because big Pharma was about to say,
fuck making vaccines.
Too many people are suing us,
so Ronald Reagan had to come and say,
keep making them all.
Make a bill where no one can see you want to be.
They can't be sued.
That didn't,
they can't be sued.
They can't be sued if Pharma gets sick all the time.
Folks for vaccines,
vaccines,
they can't get sued for vaccines.
If you want to sue anybody for vaccines or a kid gets fucked up from vaccines,
you go to the vaccine court.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a federal agency where they give out,
I don't know how many fucking buildings that damn don't have allergic reactions
to vaccines of course reactions,
but you can't,
but since 1986 what happened is since 1986 since big Pharma said,
shit,
we can't get sued.
That's when if you actually look at that,
things are not just go hook polio.
What about Polo?
What about smallpox?
When you look at what happened,
they fucking greenlit.
They're like each vaccines cause you can make truly in dog.
And they went,
so now the kid can bless his shot.
64 it's crazy.
No,
no but that,
no,
that's the prize mode.
So what?
So so,
so that would make sense.
So if you said to me,
hey bri,
the once,
once the pharmaceutical companies saw that there was a lot of money in getting
yeah,
preventative vaccines and it goes up to 64 when it used to be six or 10 or
whatever when I was a kid.
Now,
now you go,
oh well that makes sense.
Because what is big?
What does big Pharma do?
They manipulate the
FDA.
They manipulate government.
CDC,
yes.
They all this so that they write so that they can be saying something very much
like you can spirit slow
down switch teams
in a CIA operation.
Mockingbird.
It's not conspiracy.
That is,
that makes sense from a business point of view,
which,
which I can understand is insidious.
When you have huge corporations in cahoots with government can't fucking
vaccines are dangerous and shit,
they don't care.
And we can't get sued.
White tests that green.
They're convincing the sea CDC with money.
Hey pass this motherfucker.
Really Quaker points for using in cahoots in a sentence correctly.
5,000 points.
It's just common sense,
common sense.
Really.
They own the media.
You don't think the fucking people that run shit on the media,
you gotta be an idiot to fucking nothing.
The people that run shit own the media on entertainment,
on everything we can cousin gangster
shit don't on the fucking need and you don't own the TV.
Doesn't mean that you can't get credible information on a lot of topics like the
economy,
like the war,
whatever it is.
If you know where to look,
it doesn't mean you can't get credible information on the number set of what's
going on.
And that's what I'm saying.
But Eddie's port Washington Post is that the control all that,
the main stream media is all controlled.
That ain't real shit.
That's all controlled as part of the agenda.
It's all slowly inch by inch,
take away the guns and that's fucking,
that's control everybody and implode economies fucking start civil wars.
Like love that chat.
I don't think they liked that.
I think that the love that you said to me that the mainstream media and on
whether it's on the right or the left has agendas and has been corrupted and has
allowed their own personal points of view to infiltrate the news and so report
on fairly and so report in a bias fashion and the news is no longer,
I said Jack active as it was or should be now.
Now that makes sense.
If you say for example,
that gt or GE owns certain news organizations and that's a conflict of it or
could be a conflict of interest and we have to be very careful because they may
not report on ges practices.
If they're irresponsible.
Now I can have a conversation because that would make sense to me.
That would make sense because,
but when you,
when you say that everybody in the New York Times the Washington Post,
it's a CIA once you know this is what I'm saying.
There's an operation that the CIA is not a conspiracy theory,
right?
Operation Mockingbird,
they operation paperclip taken all the Nazis after World War II,
operation paperclip taking thousands of Nazi into
the government and creating NASA,
NASA,
Nazi scientists,
and you believe this,
they're masters of propaganda.
The Nazis were masters.
They put out films just to get people get they just to get people,
the people to get used to killing people.
Like if there were a certain condition,
they put out propaganda films and go watch this shit of a deranged people on the
street killing people.
People thought they would watch these news reels and they thought there was
demented people on the streets killing people.
And that was never happening.
They just wanted the people to agree that we can kill those people.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause they're crazy.
They're no one's killing anybody,
but it was all part of a propaganda gender.
Have
a little perspective on that.
So Einstein came from Germany and a lot of the Jewish scientists and the 30s
when there was this rise of antisemitism,
migrated,
immigrated to the United States.
What about the Nazis to the operation?
Paperclip was now,
and then when we realize that the Nazis were very close to creating a nuclear
bomb,
that they had some really amazing scientists.
Well,
they were,
they knew a lot of stuff that,
you know what I mean?
There was a real scientific tradition.
Remember where,
that's where Einstein came out of a lot of,
a lot of,
in fact,
the antisemitism that rose up in the 30s is y w a lot of historians have
credited the United StatesStates' ability to create a nuclear bomb before the
Nazis because of that immigration.
So antisemitism in Germany actually pushed a lot of these brilliant scientists
toward the UK,
toward the United States.
Didn't a bunch of the Nazi guys go to a Russia as well go the Russian special
Russia,
half of them went to the state,
probably will probably when Russia took,
took half of Germany,
remember?
So there was east Berlin and West that was,
um,
east Germany,
west Germany.
So when they,
when they took his Germany,
nobody's getting out of East Germany.
It was understandably.
Look,
if you're,
if you're going to be intelligent,
pragmatic,
and the war is essentially over right,
it's understandable to want to get their brightest minds of course,
and bring them over.
Of course,
you've already conquered them,
right?
This is post World War II till to let them linger and become used by the
establishment that you just defeated.
That's crazy.
These are super geniuses.
If you're a genius dude,
these guys,
but torturing,
experimenting on these physicists,
sociopath.
If we don't listen,
we don't know.
We don't know,
but I do know that the Simon Wiesenthal Center said that if Wernher von Braun,
who was the head of NASA,
they've Wernher von Braun was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes against humanity because he was instrumental
in coming up with weaponry that killed a lot of,
you know,
the allies.
It was that.
It was also that they hung the five SLU slow as Jews every day in front of his
rocket factory.
Berlin,
the ones who work the same motivations.
Yeah,
they would hang them.
These guys remembered these guys who lived in [inaudible],
the guys who lived in Miami,
come on,
hurry in the concentration camps,
they interviewed him for this documentary on,
on the moon landings and NASA and all the scientists stood behind it and they
were saying like that.
They would see those guys come in.
They would see those scientists come in and they would hang the five slow as
Jews in front of the building.
Those are the guys that say the least of what went on in Nazi Germany.
I mean,
who knows?
We don't know,
man.
I don't know what.
When I studied,
that was my area of focus in my mind.
Straight history majors and history majors.
That was my area of focus.
Not too dry.
Maybe I'm wrong about the Nazis and I'm wrong,
but they seem like they were fucking sick,
twisted motherfuckers.
That's what they see,
what they were,
but maybe they weren't.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe we was saying they weren't.
You were calling him amazing and geniuses.
No,
no,
no.
We're talking about the scientists talking about the site,
like the [inaudible],
the program programs.
Hold on it.
There's different scientists that are the medical scientist versus different
scientists that are engineers versus different scientists that are working
towards nuclear weapons.
But they were part,
they were though that,
no,
Eddie,
many of the sizes,
which you know,
and they weren't killed because they were instrumental date.
They couldn't,
they were too valuable.
Right.
NASA is fine.
So a lot of them are fine.
Well,
a lot of the inventions that were made by like the f,
the hybrid method that was made by a guy who was a Jewish guy,
which is a crazy story.
He also created something called [inaudible] a,
which had,
it was a gas that has a smell added to it.
So it would warn you that the gas was presence.
And then secondly,
the night the Nazi.
Exactly.
And the Nazis took it and they switched to design clon B.
They took the smell out of it so that you wouldn't smell it.
And then they use it in the gas chamber.
So this guy who invented the harbor method where 50% of the nitrogen that's in
most of the human beings on the planet earth comes from because that's where it,
because nitrogen is how you fertilize.
He'd create fertilizer and this guy figured out how to draw nitrogen out from
the atmosphere.
But this is how complicated he was.
He's a Jewish guy and he,
while he was like winning the,
I believe it was a Nobel prize for the harbor method,
he was also being wanted for crimes against humanity because he figured out how
to gas people too.
So this was like one,
because he was a German patriot.
I exactly,
and he was,
there was a war going on and he would,
they were using gas warfare for the first time when the allies,
so the same time that he created this method that's going to like double the
population of the world,
like sack a lot of lives,
people from starvation during the winter.
Well,
there's so much more food available now because most people don't know,
like you gotta throw something into the ground in order for the,
the soil to you.
It's supposed to be a cycle.
Things are supposed to die on it.
Those things like get absorbed.
The cert cycle of the soil.
The soil is nutrient rich,
powerful,
healthy plants grow from it,
but when you just keep putting corn in the same spot over and over and over
again,
you got to throw some shit into the soil and Fritz
harbor figured out how to get it out of the air itself because the air is like
80% nitrogen.
You think of the air as being mostly oxygen,
you know,
you think oxygen and carbon dioxide.
No,
it's mostly nitrogen is.
That's most of what's it.
So this guy is a revolving line or the Internet now that was on [inaudible].
This is just the fact to read that I saw her radio lab,
but then I've read it all over the place on the internet or in the library.
I read on the Internet.
Fuck,
that's bullshit.
Done.
Anyway,
this hobble,
hey man,
you're
just think about what I don't forget about like pumps.
Making a nonsense for a second.
Just think about what a genius you have to be to figure out how to pull nitrogen
out of the air and put it in the soil and all of a sudden everything grows
better.
Smart Dude.
But what's also amazing is that how complicated human beings are,
because it raises some really interesting questions.
The guy who invents the gas that was used on the Jews,
his own people,
however he was,
he invented chemical weaponry because he was a German patriot and wanted Germany
to win World War One and said,
I have a better way to do this.
And so you put yourself in his position.
It's a very,
it's it,
it raised a lot of difficult questions.
Oh yeah.
Well he was a super complicated person.
Yes.
But as,
as are we only,
and like many geniuses,
many like really fucking smart people like that are fucking very complicated.
Why did,
why did,
uh,
why didn't the Nazis just shoot the Jews,
like line them up and just shoot?
They did.
They did a lot of 6 million.
Why would they bother gas?
And then they got to drag them out,
put him in the shower.
They did a lot of different things.
Put them in a storm.
Yeah,
they did a lot of different [inaudible] the gas them and then they all die.
And then who's going to drag them out?
Well,
if you ever seen drags him out,
you know,
heavy boy ever happened?
No,
I'm just saying,
why am I just shoot?
Oh No,
he's saying why?
I would've thought like they did shoot him.
They slid a lot of and perverted and twisted psychos.
Exactly.
Why gas shoot him when they got,
a lot of times when they gassed him,
they didn't know they were getting guests to.
Does that make any sense?
Why not just shoot them,
drag them out.
So can I like Mexicans is the way they do it.
They dig a big ass fucking hall with,
uh,
with the,
abdominal cocktails and then they just line them up.
But you know what they did got to clean up that they can about that they're
going ahead.
But they did that in the Russian countryside.
They do,
you can see video of it.
They,
they dug massive graves and they would,
they'd make them dig their own graves and then they would just show him smart.
But what,
what happens when they drag him out of the shower,
when they got chemicals,
listen,
what they would do is when they would bring them on the trains to Auschwitz,
triplink and Dachau and all the different death camps,
they couldn't,
if they started lining people up,
what would happen?
Especially women and children hysteria.
So what they said is they get off the train after this horrible train ride and
they'd say,
here's a bar of soap.
You're going to take a shower.
That they put them all in tourism and they trick them.
They'd be in these showers,
quote unquote showers,
but some,
what's that?
Some take shower and some would be killed.
That's right.
So they didn't know.
So the strong,
so they mix it up.
The ones that look strong,
they could,
they could use for work,
they would work.
They,
they,
and the ones who are children went right away.
They don't teach ELA gassing seems so twisted it in.
So why not just make,
did a lot of horrible things.
That's what I'm talking about,
dude.
No doubts,
no words you're saying,
but hold on.
Gas To kill Jesus.
I'm like,
but there's a difference between the,
there's always going to be a difference between concentration camp guards and
scientists signed off,
but that's the same thing as us.
It's like saying that you as a martial artist,
you train people out of fight.
You probably have some connection with someone who was a corrections officer.
It's like it's,
you know what I'm saying though?
You do.
You know,
but how much do you have a an effect of what they do with their life.
The people who are working in the Er as a corrections officers are probably,
or the the,
the guards rather at Auschwitz or probably so far removed from the fucking
scientists.
It's not like they all get together and go,
we're all evil,
right?
Yeah.
What are you doing today for evil?
I'm torturing the Jews.
Evil,
all of those signs.
A percent.
That's not what I'm saying now.
I'm 100% they're all,
anybody who subscribed to that ideology is evil.
Cost Eddie.
Eddie.
Eddie was just like,
please no please.
No,
no Eddie.
You know what,
but hold on.
The scientist didn't have a choice.
They had to work you.
You,
you,
you couldn't say it to the Hitler,
the Nazi regime.
Hey guys,
I'm not going to work on your super bomb.
Listen man,
when kill you with a white with a white fucking coat on,
just in front of a beaker,
like all day those dudes went to twist it.
A cultish shit.
So like the ones that brought it in,
maybe somebody can do it.
Nazis.
It was a religion.
It wasn't just like,
oh they had a white coat and I got them a week or two to understand if there was
a lot of people that we're trying to get rid of dude to want her to fuck.
But there was people that were trying to get rid of Hitler that thought he was
crazy.
There was a lot of that going on too.
There was failed assassination attempts,
failed coup attempts that it wasn't a smooth,
it wasn't like they were all on board.
It's just he had massive amounts of power and he was a fucking terrifying
individual.
And he was a dynamic speaker.
He could get thousands of people's screen.
Hitler was that people were hurt.
Have you seen his speeches there?
So theatrical moments.
I don't know what the fuck you say you guys,
which is,
I don't know what the fuck.
No,
no,
no.
He was so well spoken.
I don't know what he was saying.
I didn't know what he say.
When you listened to that guy talk.
He's guys,
Jamie bringing out whatever he's doing.
Whatever he could,
Joey did hit that.
I'm sure.
I bet he could do Castro Castro.
Yes.
Hitler wouldn't go over well,
but guys,
if you've seen my standup,
my standup is pretty amazing.
That fucking guy.
What his limp.
How's the best?
I love him cause he only calls,
I'll never texted him.
I texted me because he just did a thing for a CSO.
He just did this,
um,
standup comedy special.
He's fucked for CSO.
Yeah.
See,
so where do you shoot it up?
Uh,
he shot it in Chicago.
Oh,
no.
Yeah.
Outside of,
um,
the theater we'll just outside of Chicago.
Rosemont was that is out there.
No,
we weren't even my specials available on Monday.
Oh,
Jesus.
I'll call you.
Call me.
Let's do it.
But you don't know the platform be,
uh,
it's going to be on iTunes.
It'll be on stitcher,
everything.
You can buy it Monday.
No polyps,
stitcher.
How's it stitcher?
I mean,
that's all I to look at it.
Stitchers uh,
for a podcast,
right?
Getting all the info on Monday.
Doesn't know.
Stitch or people,
look,
what the fuck,
Bro,
you bugged what she lived down,
man.
Hey,
what's crime?
You were always my book.
No,
you're number four.
The audio will be slipping,
Bro.
He audio will be available and I'll tell you what's really close she made today.
I want to punch you in the face.
You fucked up.
I fucked it up.
No,
it'll be on iTunes.
It'll be on Google play.
I don't think we've made one comment about the fight.
Hey,
Jake.
Jake Ellenberger,
uh,
Mazda doll.
That's a very long fucking fight.
Very good fight tonight.
But,
uh,
the rugged handsomeness of Brett Farve just distracted me for a brief moment.
I'm right.
Better,
better as he gets older,
he gives less of fuck.
You ever seen his dick pic?
Yes.
Not Sad.
Photoshop.
Hope I wouldn't allow him in the hall of fame for that came out before the hall
of fame might be an inside joke that just no one's telling you about Naza
Harari.
He's a grower,
not a shower.
It could be any thoughts on Sun.
Could it had some fun?
It might've been part of the inside joke.
Yup.
I beat the shit out of it right now.
Uh,
Brett,
he didn't even comment on,
he's just get what can you do?
Yeah.
That's the way to do it.
The best way to do it and that the best way to go scan just probably depends on
what the scandal is.
If your wiener know Anthony Wiener,
go ahead and address that shit.
They probably should,
but sometimes he's just like half fucking this fucking fight,
man.
Pedes versus hallways going to pay Max Holloway that today.
That's next week.
Hey,
what happened cowboys?
I,
is that real?
No,
it's not.
but you're talking about right.
So it's salt.
It's serves its purpose.
Yeah.
That's a fun card,
man.
It's a great car.
Holloway.
Nine in a row.
Fucking Connor had to be like,
I'm not going.
They had to strip them of belt.
Then finally he gets a title shot.
God Damn it.
Give the,
and it's kind of a fake inter cause they're like shows.
He's the champ for interim title,
but he's the chair.
Why not just give it to them?
No,
I know,
but you already have a chance to fight for their term.
I like belts.
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
If that gets Max or empty pests.
A belt.
Let's fucking ride.
I feel the same way.
I like it.
I like that fight.
Everyone gets belts.
The only thing I wonder about that fight is,
um,
I wonder how well pedis is body adapted to one 45 here's the real question is
remembered.
They weren't the main event.
Now they are five rounds.
Now
we've seen them adapt.
All right.
With two to three rounds at 45,
imagine round four and five,
the championship rounds.
Now let me ask you this,
cause he loses weight.
Is that cardio,
let me ask you this.
As a guy who you,
have you ever fought five?
Never fought five?
No.
Um,
never fought for title.
Thanks for bringing that up.
No.
Someone I met,
I know I'm just kidding.
But do you feel that the,
those like when you get in shape to go a hard three,
how much of a difference is there between the heart three and the hard five?
Is it mental like at a certain point in time,
how much more training?
Like how much in better shape could you really get?
And is it one of these things where it's just harder?
It's,
you've got to be more educated.
The pace.
Yeah.
Is it just harder or is it like does it require more time to prepare for five
rounds?
So you get in peak shape,
no matter shape is peak shape and the differences between you just having to
fight 15 minutes in the potential of 25?
Correct.
And that fee didn't use bar 25 minutes all the time.
All the city.
I usually do have seven rounds.
Yeah.
But yeah,
but the uh,
but the,
to your point,
I think it's the pacing in the early rounds because like take for instance,
Brunson,
Bruce Whittaker,
when he came out with,
oh,
he's not fighting,
you go five rounds.
Like he's just trying to get out of,
to win and get out because everyone in the world knows at that level.
You can't go for five rounds sites.
Impossible.
Ben's about to fight.
Um,
she feels like glaze and t bow and you put your hand on her shoulder.
I mean that in a good way.
Yeah.
She's,
I mean,
she's such a,
she's a morph tank she's at,
I'm a fan of hers girls.
Really strong,
powerful silver medals in the Olympics too though.
I hope
that she said it.
She said she's so good at.
And is there any woman that you've ever rolled with that,
that gave you any kind of fits or any problem?
Not to be sexist,
but beyond.
I'm sure if I rolled with Gabby Garcia,
she'd fuck me up.
Big.
Heavy on you.
[inaudible] is Davis.
They're little.
They're like 125 pounds.
one 45 hey,
let me queue up the time here so we'll actually try to wash us.
Four 402440144439 all of the first round.
It's a Sarah McMahon versus Alexis Davis,
I think.
Do you think that that stoppage when she fought Ronda and gotten hundred percent
legit,
it was Rhonda cracked or the right hand and cracked or with a knee and then put
the miniature?
Yes.
What effect meant McMahon develop some serious stand up.
She does have good standup.
She just ran into the freight train.
That is Ronda Rousey.
She also,
she's a decent fighter round.
She does a lot of things good all around.
She just needs to get,
she has muscular as fuck
dude.
How much of a bummer that dcs out,
I guess rumble as,
is that his knee or what is it?
You know Alexis surgery to Alexis Davis beat Amanda Nunez.
Yeah.
Way Back in the design.
She's tough dude,
but Rhonda just was just too much for you to be both of them,
right?
Who else?
Uh,
Rhonda B.
Both of these girls,
right?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Rhonda smushed both of them.
The frustrated both of them.
The smush Merino Sheep Mcmahon with it.
Oh,
that.
That's a good move with that elbow right there.
Shit.
That's butch.
People don't do that enough.
Look at that.
Why not just throw those short ELB?
Ooh,
that hurts shit going on and you got to react to it too.
When they throw up like that.
Edie.
Andy was the first dude.
Anytime Palae Landy back in the day in the late nineties and Brazil.
Oh,
he would do this all day on dudes cause her heart.
She's trapped now.
Those messages up to,
yeah.
Instead of her being in good position,
she's trapped.
Getting elbowed.
Well,
she's in protection mode.
Eddie,
do you remember Jason Day was like one of the first guys to figure out how to do
that from the rubber guard?
Anybody doing this situation right?
Chuck throwing elbows right now.
What is she?
What Sarah McMahon do here cause she needs to pause.
She needs to posture up or not punch because if Alexis Davis really knew how to
play some high level rubber guard,
she would never let Sara Mcmann has her hand on the mat and then have a hat on.
The chasse had the hand on the mat at the end of it.
Once the hands on the map,
boom,
it stays there.
We're not going back to check this out though.
She's about to triangle this bitch.
Ah Fuck.
I didn't mean she has a lot of potatoes.
I started
about drag.
I was
free from Fox.
You can just let those bitches loose.
You got them all corralled up and your brain and come on,
let the crowd on this side like when she on her right side,
see where Sarah Mcmahon's right arm is.
That should never be there.
When your right arm is pinned to the ground like that and you have someone with
a strong rubber guard,
especially someone who has already taken mission control with that left leg up,
the first thing to do is to trap that arm.
So once that arm is down in the ground like that,
you'd never want to give it back.
And she keeps giving it back over and over and over.
There's winning series winning this round gentlemen.
Yes,
she is.
But what I'm saying is there's a lot of opportunities for Alexis Davis offer
back.
No,
I'm wishing every time Sara McMann puts her hand onto the the ground like that.
She's extremely vulnerable
person with a very good rubber guard.
As soon as you put your arm down on the mat,
they're going to immediately over hook that arm,
try to trap it in place,
and then try to go to mission control.
She achieved mission control.
She just didn't exactly know what to do once you got there.
So she didn't try to progress any further.
And then there was a the punches.
But she,
first of all,
if you just want to elbow someone,
if you watched the Allen Day are Alan Belcher.
Jason Day fight.
Jason Day was a,
you know he beat Alan Belcher really early on when belt,
you know I'm belches of fantastic fighter and he's since then
he,
Paul Harvey said his only crime game went leg lock with a the position and beat
the shit out of him.
I love out so it's not,
it's not a dis on Alan Belcher.
I love that dude.
But Jason Day showed how effective that position could be in holding that spot
and blasting elbows in place.
So there's a lot of people that use like the first couple of steps of the
position,
but they don't know high level shit from then out.
It's a long process.
It's like I try to shoot doubles but you don't really practice wrestling
position kind of.
You know what I mean?
It's like okay,
I see you're trying to shoot a doubled.
Whoa,
look at that.
She was in a good position and she's so close to finishing this fight.
Look at this.
So close.
She's got shot.
She shouldn't hit her.
She should cinch it up cause hitting.
There's going to bash her out and she
knows she needs to pull that leg over.
She's got to scoot that punchy off.
Don't tap.
You've got 10 seconds.
The left light has got to be close with
coach Cheryl.
Oh Man.
That was phenomenal.
Alexis Davis got a lot of potential offer back.
She can be as fucking assassin.
She should should've finished that.
That was nasty.
That was nasty smell.
Mcmahon's what level you are with it?
Like my high level rubber guard players.
They wouldn't last one like 30 seconds there.
They were really rat.
That would have all just been a wrap.
You're saying pure Jujitsu guys?
Pure Jujitsu.
Yes.
Pure.
Just gut.
When punches with punches it doesn't,
it didn't even matter what the punches.
We'll make it easier.
The punches make it easier when the way you stopped Robert.
Gard don't punch.
That's live.
You wrote cop elbows you in the fucking murder.
Then you,
then you don't have,
then you're not in rubber guard.
Bang.
You're not in a rubber room.
You can't get elbowed in rubber,
so you get elbowed
me.
Talk to get a guy in rubber guard if he's aware of rubber guard.
Yes.
And then the mayor saying once,
not,
uh,
not really.
Not really.
I mean there's counters,
but then you know,
you just keep playing the game.
It's like saying,
uh,
if you try to throw that head kick due to get out of the way,
right?
Yeah.
They'll get out of the way.
But you still fucking,
there's ways to set it up.
Yeah.
You sent it out.
It's the same.
Exactly the same.
I do trust it.
I got guys all they play as rubber guard and high level guys come through all
the time and I see it,
I witness it.
I'm looking at him like I,
that's all I play.
Oh No,
no.
You go home the rabbit hole.
You're Trump.
I wouldn't be a cray.
Imagine how crazy I would be pushing or some shit that I don't even apply to.
M good leg.
How crazy,
man.
It just takes a lot of time.
This is a hell of a scram.
Beautiful takedown.
Syracuse.
Yeah,
100% he invented it.
He named it the whole deal and it was all that's innovative guys.
There were some guys that did some,
some interesting guards in the past and there was a Nieto Schembri had a lot of
really cool stuff,
but what Eddie did was he put together a system and especially a system that's
really effective Nogi and named it.
Yeah,
well he's,
he's,
and then he came out with the Eddie Bravo and invitational,
which I've heard you guys say is way more exciting to last night.
Did you watch it?
No,
but they,
but guy here,
I like CBI here.
Are we doing one Saturday Eddie and that on it invitational this Saturday.
Eddie,
look at this total potential electric chair position.
Shouldn't look.
She goes,
no,
she was,
she was in a position where she could have totally done it.
Sarah gets serious.
She keeps gaze is ridiculous,
man.
Being an Olympic level wrestler,
that's tougher to deal with.
What Sara McMann needs to do is three,
her right knee and then go to three quarter mount.
That's all she's got to do.
That's the Damien Maia route.
If she's Damien Maia.
Something else got really good control.
Have you ever wrote with Damien?
Nope.
He'd probably fucked me up.
Always bigger than you.
Well,
he's just,
he sold like he's a man.
You know what I've loved about what he does.
It's like,
so it's so old school,
but yeah,
it doesn't look like he's doing much,
but he's on top of you back
cutting right through all your bullshit.
Jibber Jabber.
He's just cut through all your bullshit and putting the smashed out on.
Yeah.
When you watch the really high level,
high level wrestlers,
it's the same thing that do things to pants and do an arm drag single legs,
but they're so flawless with it.
Well,
you know when he did it to Carlos Condit,
I was,
I just was shaking my head like,
God damn everyone.
Oh look at this man with the arm trial,
but she's still in the guard.
She's trapped into half guard.
It would be over here with
this half guard.
You don't really need,
she could take her time here.
She could just wear out right here and eventually pulled out right in the out.
Yeah.
Just go to three quarter mile.
You don't know what else.
You didn't don't really even need a mouse.
She knows what's up.
She's like,
oh,
it's just an empty rifle.
She would've just
held onto her leg.
She would have been fine.
Like man,
her handle,
she turned into the truck.
You Go away from that.
Just say this,
Sarah McMahon is the master of a side show cause it wasn't about just choking.
It was the 17 steps before that out.
She set it all up,
man.
She was on that dimension.
She's a fucking horse.
She gets it.
She got the chopping block.
You can't go horse.
He's a horse to it.
Fuck if he,
if he got that and you,
and he was fucking crabs.
Dale crushed,
crushed.
You're fucking,
you guys want to see grappling and it's like what it looks like.
Literally he's titles.
Cael Sanderson's gold medal match,
I think against this Korean guy.
Watch what he looks like.
He's like going for a walk in the park,
like he's doing ankle picks and weird shit where it looks like he's literally
kind of like,
you know,
kind of moving at half speed marijuana's yes.
Oil
Ramiro beat Cael Sanderson twice,
twice.
That's how scary dude freak athlete
chances in that fight.
She should.
She held that aunt.
She slept.
She turns it into it like I to the leg and it was done.
Hold on.
Look at Eddie.
Let me know if I'm wrong here.
Hold on the leg and turn away from the church.
It doesn't matter at that point.
You're just like that until they let go the book.
Soon as they let go of that grip,
hold on to her leg.
She held on her,
her on
the arm.
That's in the choke.
You don't want it like this.
Want it like this.
If it's like this elbow here,
you're Gotcha.
If you're like this,
you're choked.
So we want to do this.
Keeps it here.
Holding her own leg.
You're like this.
Oh.
If someone does that,
do you go to the impaler?
If they tried that,
that defense you tried to go knee to chest?
I never,
I always do.
I'm trying was from the mount.
I never let them have the opportunity to grab their leg.
You just take it right from the mouth.
I never even leave them out because if I leave them out,
they're going to do that.
If you know that,
and if you know that defense,
if you know that defense,
it stops all arm triangle.
But from the impaler I remember trying that defense.
That's mount,
that's kind of a mountain he shored up.
That knee is going to be in the way of this,
right?
But you can push that motherfucker out.
So really the best thing to do is just do a,
um,
a amount worth,
kind of like me on the belly,
but your knees on the ground,
so it's like a deep,
and he on the belly,
that's the best spot right there.
There's no defects which needs in the ground.
Say if you're on less on the belly,
right.
Same side that she just got right.
Okay.
So it'd be your left knee on her belly.
But instead of having the neat,
actually on the belly,
it's actually all the way through.
It's like your Shin across the stomach.
Knee,
really heavy on the map because if you had your knee on your belly and they knew
the defense,
they would fucking pop that motherfucker up and grab their leg and now they're
good.
And I see you have the left knee on the right side of their body and the Shin
across the top.
So there's no way they could graduate.
This is more of a mouse.
It's more of a mouse.
You might as well not,
but that is actually better than a mountain.
Well I know when you would do it,
a lot of times you would do it and we would call the impaler.
Do you still do that?
No,
I don't even need it.
That's terrifying because they stopped doing it.
It was horrific.
It was just there.
It's always there.
It's a need to,
the right to the sternum is just a massive pressure at the side choke.
So you put the shy side choke in and then the knees on the sternum.
The sternum neck.
Both,
but I mean it doesn't work on everybody,
but that's the best way to stop that defense.
Where you grabbing the leg?
For me it was always the impaler,
the impaler.
Oh,
we stopped that because you wanted so bad to get that knee off your chest.
You were willing to let your legs go.
Just try to push that knee aside and then just fall right into the church.
I don't,
I only go to the impaler when the regular shit ain't working and he's got like a
little angle has got a little spot.
It's not lined up perfect.
So now we go,
fuck it.
Let's
just hold this and drive the knee right in his neck.
And that's usually what makes him tap.
Dude,
you did the impaler on me one time and I really thought my chest was gonna
crack.
I thought my sternum was going to crash.
Jesus.
It's a terrible feeling because like someone's cranking down in your neck,
you got a head and arm trapped in there,
right?
You're the arm choke in there and then they got their neat on your shift.
It's just shit.
Eddie,
how long ago was we wrestled for a restaurant?
I see years.
Just two years.
But you were going to suck.
Really terrible.
I got one take them two years.
When did you realize that when you started rolling and Jujitsu,
when did you one realize this was it like you want to do it?
That's true.
That's what I did learn.
I did learn the twister that which is actually the rest of the wrestlers
guillotine.
Oh you weren't laughing about my shitty wrestling.
No,
I was one take down in two years.
It was after that,
but I didn't get shit out of take downs or anything.
I was actually pretty good at arm drags but you know they say it's like a bike.
I think after like 30 years,
it's not like a bike no more.
You've got to start all over.
Your body completely forgot it and you are a fucking white belt because I suck
at arm drags but I,
I in high school that was my shit.
But what was also my shit was I was a leg rider cause it was weak and I at crave
while everybody was supposed to be lifting weights,
I was on the side of the fucking the building just like,
like
so I to be a leg rider,
they every wrestling team at three leg riding.
All my wrestling my whole life.
I never,
I never once threw legs in.
I don't know why people are so good.
No,
most people don't.
There's only like three per class and I was one of those guys.
It was the week guys.
They just started podcasts.
Nico,
Chia was the guy who show up on Twitter.
I forget his last as first name something Nicco Chia.
Fuck.
Cause he's only showed me the twister.
I got a question.
Right.
What do you think's next for your boy,
Tony?
Alex Nicco Chia.
That guy is the guy who taught shut up to Algebra.
Yeah,
that's what I'm trying to do.
A shout out to Alex.
Alex,
you showed it to me.
Alex Nica Chair should be a fucking tee shirt,
but he's still alive.
Right?
He's still your positive.
Juliana.
46 [inaudible] 80
the guy was in 11th grade and I was in ninth Oh,
Gotcha.
I thought he was the coach Jesse Barrios.
He was the only other leg Raj Shadow.
So that was a twist to that.
I learned the twister in high school and then when I went to Jiu Jitsu,
I was like,
shit,
I already got it and a one move.
So I might take down suck,
but I got one move,
which I couldn't fucking do it on Jujitsu players because in wrestling you could
do it because you give up backs.
You know when you give up a back,
you stick a leg hook in.
It's really easy.
But in Jujitsu,
giving the back is the ultimate sin.
So it was like,
damn,
what?
No one's even giving me their fucking back.
How am I going to do this?
Only the,
the only move I know in grappling and then so slowly I had to figure out how to
get to the wrestlers guillotine,
which later became the twister because Hagen and John jock named it.
That shit I didn't
out truck was your original teacher,
right?
Yes.
What a great guy.
John.
John,
is this a promotion for these two fighting?
What's going on right now?
I can't hear shit.
It seems like it's a two below gets the title now because he wanted the interim
title with Frankie and now they're showing pedis highlights the showtime kick
and it's a little weird.
He's fighting for a title.
Yeah.
Cause he's lost two of those last three.
Um,
what,
what happened in his last fight?
He Won.
He beat who did he beat?
Olivera right.
That's right.
He submitted him.
Yep.
And before that he lost.
Look,
he's still Anthony motherfucking pedis dude.
He was still,
I love the summer.
You're gonna win some doesn't mean like,
oh,
it's over for him.
Like he's,
he just got fired.
No one saying it's over.
I'm saying it's a little strange that he's getting a title shot.
That's what I'm saying.
My question to life now at four 45 is fucking Stan.
Anthony Pettis was the 55 champ.
It was cancer two years ago.
45.
It's like,
yeah,
he's going to be right there in the mix.
That's my momma,
man.
That's Anthony fucking pen for 45 it's always one nightmare.
Okay,
well Max all we won nine in a row and he's just getting a title shot and is true
fan the UFC just,
you know that it's a good point.
I'm just saying that I love Andrew,
but it's one of my favorite people in the UFC.
I'm scared of what's going on with,
I'm scared of,
of the direction that UFC is going for some reason should be
all of us.
It used to be that it was Dana,
the end,
the Renzo and frank was right there,
but it was like you had faced whatever like you need,
you could actually get to them and like make a change.
Like if something,
it was like doing the right thing for the sport.
It was all about every buns.
We're all here,
we're working together,
we're doing the right thing for the sport,
the right rules for the sport.
We're trying to make it right and now to this,
those guys don't even fucking own the UFM.
I said,
who is it?
That shit when you start looking at owns when you still faceless famous people,
you six hours,
seven basically not faceless.
There's,
there's already a manual gate.
Dana White,
Conan O'brien.
There's a few,
it's a few celebrities in particular.
I met Ari,
I've talked to Orange is a very nice guy.
I'm sure he is very smart guy.
He listens.
He's,
he's really wants to,
that's good to hear.
He wants to do the best thing they can cause poor.
Who knows what kind of changes they'll make once they settle in and get a get
it.
But these guys are masters of entertainment business.
They know how to handle things,
but the fans of the sport but also it,
and for it on the fighter's side,
that mixed martial arts,
uh,
athletes association is the first time where it's like a serious issue for them
to address.
Let me ask you this,
how many different unions are there?
I heard there's more than,
I'm not sure about.
I tell you this or that,
that it's a mixed martial arts athlete's Association,
which I'm part of.
Tim Kennedy is,
was there.
So there's four board members,
right,
right.
And they just announced it.
They have over 200 fighters right now on board with it.
So first like legit movement of it.
Now what does that entail?
Like when you're on board.
So that means like if you go to fight for uh,
you know you have a,
a UFC fight coming up.
Like how does that or a bell tore,
right.
Cause it's for everything,
right?
It's for everything.
It's just for,
it's for any organization that's mainly made up.
Especially right now,
major UFC player.
She was a good question.
Does that hold true for like rises and stuff like that?
Like what about um,
if you fight overseas,
I'm not sure.
So the idea is,
you know,
their focus is UFC cause the top dog,
so if you start at the top is going to trickle down.
So the idea is that they're going to have a like a set a set amount of money or
we're going to make per fight,
correct.
Basic basically.
And they're modeling after it after the base,
while union,
which is like the best in the world as far as compensation and equal rights.
Good stuff.
This is good stuff.
Great stuff.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Is there an essential,
is there any potential?
Yeah,
well a bunch of UFC fighters,
which is Tim Kennedy,
Donald Cerrone,
which is a big one.
GSP.
Tj Dillashaw was really weird with Tim Kennedy said love.
You hear what Tim Kennedy said about beyond those and he was like a necessary
evil.
He's,
he's basically like the,
the WHO.
Who's your boy from Nalco?
Not your boy.
He found me on the show.
Victor Conte from Victor Conte was on the dark side and then he came out.
It was like,
I know how this shit works now for the good guys.
I'm gonna tell you what they're trying to do.
Right.
That's what Bjorn is doing.
He's like,
when they say this,
this is what he means by this.
Wow.
Well you know who the fuck knows.
Cause I suspect when I saw Bjorn I was like,
I can't be,
you know,
I've heard stories about something like I don't want to be part a.
And then when I talked to Tim Kennedy,
that mother Fucker talk me in to run through a wall.
Who's taken my goal in one spot
is not Mike Goldberg is not part of the MMA association.
There's rumors.
He was,
he's not that.
That'd be kind of conflict of interest,
but the thing is is about Bill Goldberg.
Yeah,
the dude's familiar with the rest.
No.
Whoopi Goldberg like we all hire you
over and made a come back,
man.
Yeah,
he thought he played in the NFL,
which I didn't know.
He's a guy called the Goldberg.
He's a giant dude.
You're on it.
You're on the Goldbergs.
Yes,
I am.
That's the one where you're like a coach.
You're a coach.
I'm not only my coast,
but they're doing a spinoff on ABC as the character.
Holy Shit.
It's kind of exciting.
It's cool.
Yeah.
That's awesome dude.
It's about time.
Dude.
You're a funny motherfucker.
You may be lost in politics.
I'll never forget that new year's fucking me,
dude.
Dude,
you had me.
Fuck Dude,
you crushed my soul.
I heard you laughing from the wings.
By the way,
if you like laughing this weekend for learn other than profit,
that's all I'm going to say.
Come see me.
That places that shit,
dude.
My favorite place to play.
And you go there,
you go there a lot.
I don't go there nearly enough.
I go there once here.
That's wish I could go.
Yeah.
And I love it so much.
We're going to bring the fighter and the kid there.
We have to cause that.
Is that in Florida or fucking savage?
Greatest.
My greatest shows her at the Fort Lauderdale Improv.
How Beach Florida this weekend.
Florida people are savage.
Eddie.
I can hear you laughing.
It was so great.
We were,
we did the Chicago Theater 3,500 people and I'm listening to Eddie cackle in the
wings.
It was beautiful.
Let's be a fun one.
Are you guys doing some kind of new,
there's a show that's fucking insane.
Oh,
you know what I did?
I did.
Uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe is there,
right?
Tony and Joey Diaz.
Tony just started his podcast.
I was his first guest yesterday at the comedy store called the Pony Hour.
I named it.
That's perfect.
He was like,
I don't have a name.
I said,
sir,
it's the pony out.
How did the Orpheum come on?
How did that,
has got some nip you ever played there before?
Bird suck those bill Byrd did new year's there last year saw iron man and I was
just looking for a place to do new year's and when the agents look for theaters
that are available,
that's the one that came to me with.
That's a good one man.
So that's another place for me.
I love that place.
That's our hall was excited and I met the owner.
I'm at your boy element is the bad.
How many does it say?
Shout out to Steve.
Where's this?
Where's the door?
If the Orpheum and downtown La,
how many does it seat go?
1900 damn.
That many big shattered dude.
He did 3,500 well no,
no,
no.
Excuse me sir.
No,
I'm just saying the Orpheum when I was there for Eddie,
I didn't know it sat that many people.
Pretty sure cause we were down on the front of them and it looked all right.
No,
no,
no.
19 I think it's 18 or 19
something like lead or man,
that's one of those places where you look at it and you go,
Whoa,
when Steve First asked me to do Ebi is there,
cause we were doing it with the floor king gardens initially at the in
Hollywood.
I W I looked at the website,
I'm like,
Oh man,
this guy does and he obviously doesn't know what you do.
You ever see this is too classy for Jujitsu.
We're dirty motherfuckers.
So I just turned it down and then he again,
it said,
just come down and check it out.
And I'm like,
okay.
I went down,
checked it.
I'm like,
dude,
this is like you do like the Oscars and shit here.
Why would you want Jujitsu?
But he's so into Jujitsu.
The guy that owns Orpheum,
he's dude,
man,
he's doing privates with Capella and he's so he competes.
He's 65 and his complaints a strong motherfucker.
That's such an awesome guy.
And he do when we show up and he's got his Ebi shirt on,
he's got his 10 plan a shirt on.
The guy who owns that whole fucking thing loves Ebi.
Like he seemed like a super talk to him.
He's a super fan.
So when they brought to me the options of places to go,
that was one of the first ones.
I was like,
yeah,
I love that place.
You want to be in La Joe?
New Jersey.
What date does that fall on?
On a Thursday.
I think it's Saturday.
Jamie.
Yeah,
Saturday night on a Saturday night because there's a UFC on Friday because UFC
didn't want to come to New Year's Eve.
So that's the Ronda Rousey.
Amanda Nunez fight.
Oh,
Shannon.
Max Holloway and Pedis.
That's next week.
No one's here to fight.
It's not Max Holloway.
When,
when is that fight?
Max Holloway.
And Anthea pest is December 10th.
What does the other fight next week?
What does the other fight?
Uh,
the other fight is a cowboy Cerrone now.
That's right,
Matt Brown map out.
Okay.
See I have those both in like the same level of expectation.
I just don't have the answer.
I look at Pettis Holloway and then I'm looking at,
uh,
look,
I think Matt Brown,
it's always death.
It's always destruction.
It's always hell.
You know,
training together.
They've trained together at muscle.
Well how was that?
Give us insight
whenever they tell me
don't,
don't do that.
But listen,
I mean everybody knows I'm a big Matt Brown fat boy.
He's a killer.
How boy at one 70 is a video game character.
Oh,
he's a video game.
Character works people.
I'm training.
He smirks.
He's doing something different now because he's not fucking his body up to make
one 55 we're seeing 100% cowboy.
He's got so much.
Don't give a fucking him that to take a guy like that and like extract all the
water out of his body and drained them and deplete him.
You deplete some of that spirit that makes him exceptional.
When that guy is healthy,
it's like a lot of what I call it carries into the octagon with him.
It's like this zest for life and it comes out when he's fighting.
You know like that gets depleted when you bodies look at common fact.
How good to kind of look at 55 insane.
We should fights.
I believe so.
It's like cheese,
except obviously way too much.
He should five.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
He should have Aldo come up to you and can't see shit.
Let's just get this done.
All those set that it goes.
Let me beat the winter of Max and in pedes I'll win that belt.
I'm coming at 55 he should.
I'd love to.
Well,
but the beach in 19 seconds.
Let me rematch,
Nate.
Oh,
I might fight Josie.
Doesn't he have a motherfucker of a time?
55 this guy's got tits.
He's cute.
Joe Say's had some real issues and get
the whole campaign with Cisse.
Now God damn you
walk right up to that guy.
Throat famous fighter.
He's going to be a star.
What is he up?
He scared fucking scares in this country.
What if he just gets knocked out at vicious head?
Kicked in five seconds.
Let me see.
I got to sit on your lap for this dude.
Yeah,
I'm scared,
dude.
He's got some tech path.
Nema.
That's a bitch ass shit.
Why can't do that after you do the other thing?
Definitely kid,
he's going to get lit up.
Powerful Rico.
Michael Clarke,
Duncan.
Hey Man,
he does look like a good uppercut.
Oh,
he's not fucking around.
He's already hurt throat slash and not fucking come out of booming.
Oh,
what if he gets knocked out though?
[inaudible] then he will never do this ever again.
He made us play mean.
It's a psychological good move,
but it's,
it's kind of negated by the fist bump.
The fist bump brings a confidence level back up.
A solid shirt.
Well,
cannoneer is got to get over it.
The God factor,
the guy's face looks so intimidating and once he does,
he's going to win.
Yeah,
Brian,
I don't think he's looking at his face anymore.
Now they touch gloves again.
There's a lot of unity going on the ship and,
and he's going to touch with the right hand that's going to favor cannoneer
keeps his hands down.
Guys.
It's about,
it's about fundamentals.
I've always told you,
you guys,
it's about fundamentals.
I believe I've heard that from you.
That's something you really do.
This guy's an animal.
I do recreational boxing and I'm a blue belt in Jujitsu.
You know my problems.
My problem lately with the MMA is that I've been watching too much.
Moitai oh,
watching.
I've been watching a ton of Moitai lately.
You're a stickler for technique.
Well,
it's just,
I just recognize there's another level to be achieved that you're,
you're seeing like,
especially with striking with a lot of guys,
you're seeing like a certain level of technique well on a consistent basis
because it's,
they have to concentrate a lot of different things.
Yeah,
I know,
I understand that.
But it's hard when you have a few guys that have achieved like,
like this Rory Macdonald's sort of spectrum and they can kind of do everything
really good at a very high level.
Like you remember when Roy McDonald fought JT tourism metamorris yeah.
Tinchy towards very high level Jujitsu guy.
Roy Hung out with them,
almost got Kimora,
didn't tap holes.
Got his arm broke.
Yeah.
But ultimately went to a draw,
like fight.
Uh,
um,
what's his name?
The guy that the really high level French striker,
um,
uh,
tarkes avatars half.
Yes.
And he came up with a whole different style.
I was watching shows like Joe is it about the evolution of the sport?
Like Roy started MMA when he was 12 MMA.
He didn't specialize in anything.
So you're going to see like,
you look at fucking homeboy,
uh,
what's his name with the spiky here,
it looks like a more
Northcutt.
He's also a kid who started,
so you're going to get this wave of guys who just do wellness.
Sage started with karate and he's way more of a karate guy that needs a Jujitsu
guy.
It's not that he's not better at Jujitsu now.
I mean he definitely showed that in his last fight and he submitted guys in the
past.
He,
he's just a young kid.
Yes.
Fruits,
genetically fantastic athlete.
Who's a young kid who's got a lot of life to learn guard against Micky Gall.
When the fuck is you saying rip that Apple and that's a barn burner.
When is that?
Ah,
no.
That fight is somewhere else.
Am I wrong?
I feel like that fights.
Sage Northcutt is a fun fight.
I feel like that fight is somewhere else.
Mickey calls him fucking get C's in my car is a motherfucker.
It's very good.
I think he's more talented than sage Northcutt.
Oh,
I think he's extremely talented and I love how many calls the guys out.
Big Kid,
but we've seen two real good fights from mum and of course one of them was
against.
Oh there it is,
right?
There's Saturday the 17th UFC fight night.
Two cans.
Michelle Waterson boys.
I'm not going to be here for you all in Japan too.
How dare you can damage your eye a favor.
This is the problem with having family.
Where are you going man?
Where are you headed?
Just go.
I go on a lot of vacation shirt done.
I wish I could try to.
I want to just,
this is I'm,
I'm in the,
I just want to live life phase of my life.
I just want to experience that I'm not good at vacation.
I want to go places.
I want to experience things.
I get better all the time.
You know what helps me?
Edibles,
boy.
Really Knowledge.
Boy,
you got it.
But you know the certain place where you can get them.
Don't bring them though.
They're pretty easy to get.
Don't bring him.
Definitely not worth it.
I put my paper everywhere when we do like should I bring him everywhere?
Amin,
Tsa,
we're homies mean TSA or cools.
Fuck how I asked Brian and a few years pass.
What's up in a few years there's going to be places where they have like the
spots where you could vape up at the airport.
Well like to have wine bars right next to those will.
There'll be counselors,
therapists,
and just start fucking crying and thinking about their dad.
Oh Shit.
I just use it to calm down and turned my brain off.
I can't do it.
I don't do it during the day.
This dude is heavily muscled.
Which guy?
The black guy.
White Fella.
Yeah.
You're looking too much.
The white guy built better black guys.
Jack,
fine,
but I just like the white guy.
White Guy can identify with them.
No,
look,
they're both Jack.
They're both jacked,
but that was a confused opening.
We're going to talk to that guy about strategy.
Do we really do?
Don't ever fuck them.
They went a slash and I was all just for place.
Let's touch gloves.
Let's be friends.
Yeah.
Unless you're the mother fucker of motherfuckers and it doesn't matter.
Right?
You come out and Conor Mcgregor,
I'm with a straight left and just put them away.
He didn't.
It doesn't matter if you touch gloves degree.
Do you remember when Conor Mcgregor talked a freight train full of shit against
Dennis Seaver and then beat his ass beat when they got into the octagon?
Before the fight,
he read to shake hands with Dennis.
Even Dennis Eve or wouldn't put his hand out.
He goes,
fuck you.
And then he went out merch dumb.
You can't do that to CBRE.
Cbre was in their lights.
Only had that spinning back kick in his wheel house.
I understand,
but you know,
then the CBREs like I'm from
Germany,
you fuck,
we're not having this.
And then the Scot model.
Wow.
The world is a better place because a condom McGregor,
100% how about he got his boxing license,
Joe Boxing license.
Do you see that?
Yeah.
Do you see what he said?
Did you see,
did you see Oscar de la Hoya drunk as fuck?
Talking about
this corner,
that corner he was talking about Conor McGregor fight.
Canelo Alvarez.
I love Oscar silver up,
but on my giant too.
People forget how fucking talented the
fight at the forum.
Yo,
you ever see them fight the first round when he lit up,
Julio,
Cesar Chavez,
I said,
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
That boys legit time.
I was talking,
I saw that close circuit TV at the La where the clippers used to play.
What was that?
Not the La Forum,
but the La,
the Great Western Forum and all his La arena loss.
Sandra fucking the clippers arena.
They had closed circuit.
Remember these?
They do that.
You'd go to an arena and watch the screens of the boxing.
I was a big Oscar fan of big Julio Cesar Chavez Fan.
I was torn.
I had to go with the one who was more Mexican.
I had to go.
He didn't stick.
You know what the mix is a real Mexicans.
He like,
Yo can't even speak English.
[inaudible]
listen to this for say I go with him.
I'm going to tell you how legit Oscar de la Hoya is.
He fought Julio,
Cesar Chavez and Bernard Hopkins.
What's that?
Manny Pacquiao and may pack.
You'll be went all the way.
The fuck up and sugar Shane all do and sugar.
Shane went to Bernard hub.
What the fuck is [inaudible]?
Who was the 175 counties?
World champions.
You went up to him.
John,
his fight with Fernando Vargas.
Boy,
a lot of shit talked before that fight to the public can do to and doing.
Very good.
Hey,
ask your boy your boy hush.
Hush.
Hush,
hush.
I'm all that.
That's your boy hockey about,
no,
I'm just saying it's hush hush upon all that.
Amen.
Yeah.
Listen,
people have fun.
Let's protect it.
Oscar.
I hate,
I love Oscar.
He got punched him sprawl hard.
Elbows on top shouldn't get just a good fire.
What's really cool about MMA is that you can't really be the very best at
everything.
You could be the best to put it all together for your specific body.
You bring the best at handling pressure in your division,
but you can't be the best Jujitsu guy.
The best kickbox are the best wrestler.
You don't have time.
So many super athletes out there that it's almost impossible for one person to
be the very best at everything.
That's one of the things that makes MMA so exciting is because you see this
collision of different strategies and you'll see one strategy work for a long
time and you go,
hey,
ground and pound is where it's at.
I remember when Vitor Belfort got up to 240 pounds because that was the mother
fucking Mark Coleman era who turns wine on was for a little while while he was,
but see,
this is what happened.
That's what you get was just tackling dudes and smashing their fucking faces and
everybody panicked.
Do you remember when you interviewed?
He was
interviewed him one time and this was like literally 1516 years ago,
joined and Marco's Joba.
So what's your strategy and Mark Marcus,
I'm going to beat the fucking shit out of him.
No,
no,
no.
He,
he was drunk,
but first of all that's scared.
I'd never seen you get scared,
but I love mark and mark and I had been friends for a long time.
So even though I was scared,
I was reasonably sure he wasn't going to hurt me.
But he picked me up like a pillow.
Like I was a pillow and he spun me around the hair long ago.
Maybe a day,
maybe a day.
A day.
Dude,
he's so strong.
I remember you said to me,
you were stammering.
You Go,
hey man,
I was fucking scared.
He's so strong.
He's like,
I felt like I've never felt lighter.
I was like,
I'm going to pick them up,
throw them around and beat the fucking shit.
I didn't know.
He goes,
he goes,
who's,
I'm taking him down.
I'm going to ground down the fucking shit out of him.
I was like,
Oh shit.
I was asking him about him coming and you stammered.
I to forget,
I'll never forget when I met him the first time I met him,
it was after he got beat by Maurice Maurice Smith.
And if you were a member,
he was supposed to crush Maurice Smith.
Kickboxers coming very well.
And at that point striking was useless at that point,
striking was useless.
And Mark Coleman emerge after hoists.
So here comes Maury Smith,
the striker,
he don't know any digits.
You don't know Russell,
he's going to get fucked up.
But he beat him on cardio.
Right?
Cause remember Mark Homey like taking them down leg kicks.
He got also give credit to frank shamrock cause frank shamrock worked a lot with
Maury Smith before that fight.
And one of the things they developed as a really good butterfly guard for
Maurice.
Maurice kept elevating marks.
Hips kept moving around a lot,
a very hard guard to pass.
Very Good Smith,
Maurice Smith.
What Maurice Smith had been most guys didn't happen in the early days is you
couldn't pass his guard.
He had a very good butterfly garden.
He know how to retail and use Lothrop done shit back in the day.
So,
so uh,
Marc Coleman kept taking him down at will but he couldn't finish him off.
He didn't have any.
Here's another point.
He was in his late guy.
His Fun.
I love Maurice.
Cause another important,
very important point if you are,
if you are a an outstanding world class kickboxer like his,
he is the same principles of defense apply on the ground with ground and pound.
It's harder to move your head backwards,
right?
But a guy like that is significantly harder to hit than a guy who's not used to
taking punches.
Sure.
Front of someone just turned on many and freezes up.
So when he sees these big bombs come coming,
he's doing a lot of this.
Yeah,
he's grabbing you.
He's,
he's not going to sit there.
And of course there are guys that are overwhelming.
There's guys like,
like I keep bringing up cro cop versus Gonzaga cause the second fight with cro
cop got revenge when he got on top of Gonzaga.
I'm like,
when you see a world class striker,
drop elbows on your head from the guard.
He doesn't need to be in the mount.
He doesn't need to be inside control.
Cro Cop just needs that amount of space and he is opening your head like a
fucking coke and shatter my nose.
Oh dude,
it's so,
so impressed by that elbow.
He dropped down Gonzaga.
I'm like,
see,
I knew it.
If you could get an Ernesto hoost on top of you on your mountain of devastation
on top of that,
he was the strongest guy you'd ever,
you don't Mirko was supposed to fight Wanderlei soon in rising.
I thought Mirko No.
Vandelay to violate for no.
I don't know why.
I Dunno why,
but Mirko was saying all kinds of crazy shit about who knows.
He might get an injured,
I don't know.
Let me fuck no.
Let me finish my Maurice smart goes.
I would love to see so camp back then,
by the way,
Mark Coleman,
so in her house,
logs on your back,
running up hills,
fucking each other up when Mari Smith Five.
Dot.
Mark Coleman,
his pre fight footage was hidden running upstairs.
It was either that fighters fight with Ken and Sylvia Sylvia era,
but I remember him,
he interviewed a,
Hi,
I'm Maurice Stans.
I've been kickboxing intended,
I'm a world champion.
And then show him like running upstairs and shit and like a football stadium.
That was his B roll and that's how he beat Mark Coleman.
And he beat him on and you know he'd beat them on car.
Mark Coleman was fucking holding his knees.
He was like bent over and,
and Mari Smith's just start a fucking leg kicking him and beating the shit out
of his legs.
But let me tell you this,
Maurice Smith was probably the first guy to ever talks shit in the middle of a
world championship fight.
This is back when I was the post fight interviewer.
He was going,
come on mark grunted pump me mark.
Come on.
Mark [inaudible],
Mark Growney,
he'll forget Maury Smith was every bit of 230 pounds.
Maurice,
since it was the first guy to incorporate,
like,
like first got incorporate high kick in like a world championship fight.
When he fought Conan and era.
Yes,
he fought Kona and Sylvia and world extreme cage fight.
I remember that shit he hits,
that was back when John Perretti was the interview was the,
he was doing my job.
John Perretti shout out to John Perretti should love John Jansen.
Adversial I love that guys commentary.
Always loved his coffee shop ready with the stunts.
Shout out to him.
He worked in stance on Oz back.
So I got,
I sent me a fucking direct message on,
uh,
on Twitter one day and you know,
I know everybody gets busy,
but he is,
I'm not shitting on him.
He sent me a direct message,
like I always had respect for you.
You know,
I,
I can't believe that you wouldn't have me on your podcast.
So I sent him a text message,
John Perretti.
So I sent him a Twitter message back.
I was,
dude,
I'd love to have you on my podcast.
I don't know what you're talking about.
If somebody,
whoever said that is definitely,
there's definitely encouraged.
But I was,
I was always a fan of John [inaudible] and he never heard back.
They've heard back from him,
but if I did hear back from him,
but if he hears this,
I got nothing but respect for John Preti.
I enjoyed his commentary back in the day.
I thought he was fun and honest and he knew the fuck.
He knew a lot of shit about fighting God dog.
We got a scrap here.
Are Boys getting fucked up?
Yeah,
he's guys doing the throat slashing.
he's getting,
he's getting beat up singing some shots but like John Pridey doesn't get the
respect he deserves.
There was no one before him.
You have to understand this guy was like literally one the very first guys who
was a high level mixed martial artists.
Did you Jitsu kickbox and was doing commentary for MMA.
He was like one of the very first guy to show that battle king show.
Exactly which had some great fucking fights for the world was so pissed because
he's very direct.
He's very first.
He's one of the first promoters have personalities and they're like,
you're going to have to have a certain personality to deal with the fighters.
The staff man,
he spoke,
but live Johnson and his mind like John John Brendan's out on the set and that
guy was not interested in being a diplomat or your friend.
He was just very direct and very honest and had the confidence built like a
brick shit house by the way.
Yeah,
we had a good conversations back when I used to work for the UFC back in
[inaudible] 97 and I never got to know him.
Well,
you know,
and then I took a break and then the UFC,
they sold in his shop ready wasn't there with any more hands up bro.
So nice fist.
Oh,
he's backing him down back to the Mark Coleman in his hand.
Never let any brought a fit Mark Coleman stove for all that.
Maury Smith Beats Mark Coleman.
I go to a UFC and in Louisiana I need Joe Joe's doing backstage commentary.
I go down there with Ricky,
rocket drummer from poison were like hanging out like let's go see a UFC.
It's in a small 3000 seat arena.
Just a bunch of crazy motherfuckers and Kemper,
Louisiana in 1997 when Frank Shamrock,
a double leg,
Igor is innovative and broke his clavicle and that was the end of the fight that
was managed them.
When Mikey Burnett beat up fucking Eugenio Tad.
That's old school shit.
Most of y'all don't remember that shit,
but that's old school shit.
I was actually there live met Joe Vito was there yet.
Remember yet if you throw out a white,
uh,
it was awesome.
But he was all young and shit.
But anyways,
I rent a home.
That's when met Eddie Bravo and I became friends.
I was like,
we can veto like he's on my fucking set of Miami Vice.
We were just cracking up [inaudible] I was like 19 years old.
Looked like a fucking
like a buff ass.
Changed your life and read getting glasses.
But anyways,
so I run into Mark Coleman at that show.
This is the end.
I promise.
I did all that.
She was a setup Marcola match it to set up and I'm like grilling.
I'm like asking him all these questions.
I'm like,
so this is after the Maurice Smith fight where he gassed.
I go,
dude,
uh,
what are you going to do?
What did you learn from that fight?
And he goes,
what are you going to do different?
He goes,
brother that down on my feet.
I like jogging shoes on that Nike's cause I'm running,
I'm running
increases.
Look at my
tennis shoes on and we're at the UFC.
Um,
I should be having some fucking boots on or some tennis shoes.
Well,
I'll give you a recent story.
It's not the shit I'm going to come.
And I sat next to him at a live belt where I went to and he had some of the best
stories of all time,
but he is a chatty Cathy.
I could,
I was listening to him tell stories.
I missed every single fight,
man.
He's the right dude.
Here's my advice.
In the fucking future.
You DVR the fights.
You go back and you watch me joy time with one of the fucking hall of famers,
Mark Coleman.
He was heck destroyer.
He was like destroyer for why you should be.
You should have been buying him beer and lean in your ear in his direction.
He wouldn't give me an inch either.
I was squished.
It was the hands,
bottom Tequila and drinks.
I didn't have a chance to buy.
It's Mark Coleman.
That's great.
He kind of had a little,
but then he won that pride.
Fucking grandpa came back strong.
Dude.
He was fucking Vegas.
Remember stayed working crazy.
His body was Mark Coleman and pride dude.
He was like,
he's strong
lately.
He choked out.
Dan Henderson,
would that scarf hold?
Remember that he had them like a side headlock scarf.
Old type situation.
I remember when he had an idea,
and excuse me,
um,
Dan Severn,
did I say Henderson,
et Cetera.
That was the shit.
Mark Coleman for awhile.
That was a shit.
I'm going to hit block you and fucking,
that's a legit model when you're that strong.
And he said,
hey brother,
a skill of a strong,
he's strong,
but that's a skilled move.
I know.
It's true.
I know it is though.
He worked hard.
He would do that.
He's 7,975 pounds,
and he was really good at just taking that side headlock and just fucking
balancing
zit doing.
It's not just a strong man move.
It's actually a real move that people just don't,
uh,
explore.
But I,
there's a guy named dude am the fucking,
tap me with that shit in a headlock and he's hundred and 75 pounds.
Like a big dude.
Dude.
I was very talented.
Hey,
before I forget,
what was the Duda there was a like a move from it's rubber guard move.
It's like a in the rubber guard family after just trying to get a Zombie.
It's like you can't,
it's a halfway through your hands through it and you just do a Bicep crusher,
right?
Your legs.
I remember it,
but I don't remember how old your shit and do out or this guy's getting crazy.
That guy has a whole system around her and there's nobody on the planet like
that motherfucker with that shit.
I never seen anybody from the guard setting up risks,
fucking biceps smashers and flipping,
enrolling people in 30 seconds.
Fuck three,
not 38 seconds.
This one.
People were giving a standing ovation look pretty good.
Yeah.
Well it's always interesting.
Next two fights or big gives the fucking Kaboom is getting much better.
Good boxer.
This said next slice.
Yeah,
we definitely was way more calm on his feet when he stood in front of them and
it was like,
well you also realize this dude was kind of gassed out.
You get a little emotional with the fight.
You know you're either a killer or you want everybody to think you're a killer
or killers or like fade or never did any of that stupid shit.
Quiet.
Can't leave Cain.
Cain Velasquez is my all time favorite way in face cause like he doesn't give a
fuck thing.
He's like,
Oh shit.
I to be a little nervous.
I'm going to have a PA tank of gas and I'm going to rain bombs down on you until
it's all over.
Bitch.
When does he fight next?
December 30th he's fighting December 30th but man,
there was just some surgery.
What the fuck is he need surgery.
You say?
I don't want to hear that.
It's like his 12th surgery since he's been in.
But you can't say you got a fight coming up and then afterwards you're going to
get surgery.
No sound because that's a ridiculous thing to say.
That's the life they live,
brother.
I understand.
But to say it publicly seems pretty ridiculous.
Efficient insurance involved.
It's a good point from a business move,
but as a fan you got to appreciate the honesty.
He goes,
it's true too.
It was really,
I should have surgery,
but I don't want to beat this motherfucker so bad and get to the title shot.
I'm going to wait and do it after.
Here's a good question.
Do you think you say he does look very helpful?
It looks very clean.
Let me ask you this.
Do you think that insurance should cover all of the injuries sustained during
training,
which of course all of them are.
Yes.
100% right.
I agree with.
Is that the case right now?
Like what does insurance cover now?
Does it only cover things that happened in a fight?
No,
it covers,
uh,
I'm almost positive you got asked when your UFC boys,
but I'm pretty sure it covers when you're in training camp for that fight.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Like certain amount of weeks outside of training camp as you're preparing for
the bout.
But if let's say I have nothing scheduled,
I get hurt.
It doesn't cover that.
So that's the case then it doesn't,
then what he said was actually kind of gangster.
Yeah.
Super gangs.
Cause he's already covered by insurance and he's going to come in and say,
look,
I know I'm kind of injured here,
but I'll deal with it and your ass.
Yep.
How great is that?
That's pretty good.
All Mike Brown warming up must get the early.
Frankie Edgar had a fucking pretty significant knee injury leading up to the
fight with Jeremy Stephens.
Well how about for doom?
They said he went into the fight against trash with a broken foot.
Me Lie jumping side kicked him in.
The face landed that shit dumb.
They tricks and wobbled first food for the fight,
man.
So gangster man.
Oh,
fighting hard enough,
let alone with broken.
That was just what they'll,
Travis Browne to crazy things happen to him in that fight.
There's that kick that he opens up with like,
where the fuck is this coming from?
And then,
um,
when Verdomme threw that punch and hit his finger is,
oh my God,
this is a call.
I see the crazy,
he snapped his friend.
You,
you wouldn't have waited a second.
Right?
That's he spare fucking game there.
Oh,
he's,
I call I went skews me.
Yeah.
You want to kick you right in the face.
Oh,
it's awful.
It's a weird thing man.
Because if he says,
excuse me,
I'm done.
It's over.
My finger's broken.
Then they stopped a fight,
then you're correct and not attack him.
But I went just get a second limit my finger.
I mean,
but here's the thing.
I didn't want that fight to end right there to Ju [inaudible] I went to stay
dead.
Do you want to leave room for an emotional mistake in a time of duress like that
where someone might have fun?
You,
Kay,
you ready to go on?
He's okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then jumps back in like there's moments where something could go wrong.
Well you don't even realize like this there a malfunction of my glove.
Yes.
Why's my finger bed sideways?
Hold on.
What the fuck's going on?
Yes,
there is moments but,
but
you know you'd take it back to game of fucking Thrones.
They would let him draw the line.
I'll tell you what.
I'm going to come around.
It's like an iPad.
No Shit on both these.
The reason why that doesn't count is because it didn't happen from him going for
a on this sketch it happened because for June threw a punch at La aimed at his
hand and that broke his finger
in your nose right now,
Travis Travis,
Travis had his hands up and for doom through one of them.
Crazy Chuck Odell style or brand,
but it was a pie ended on the fingers.
Correct.
That broke his finger broke
up.
Yeah,
you're right.
Function of that injury is,
you could argue is poor technique,
right?
Because that might hold technique that might work with MMA.
Where with boxing gloves rather,
a more tech gloves,
you know,
to have your hands
like this and to have a kid coming at you and held your hands and also helps
them to braise.
It gives us more space.
If we could see it.
Let's see if we can see it,
but break John Jones about having an open hand.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well that's,
that's authentically though.
Let's look at,
let's look at,
let's look a good pot bottle.
I liked that.
That's a good point in time.
Breaking a finger
fingers.
How often do practice punching fingers
in the gym?
Once a week or twice a week.
I don't practice snapping.
Arms are knocking guys out.
Hold on.
That's your frankness.
Our bars.
Let's look.
Practice armbars.
How could you not break his arm bar?
No.
Practice snapping natural art.
No bars aren't snapping arms.
Guys were looking at this fight right here.
This is a,
the punch where that landed,
I mean authentic move by for doom,
but I can't fault anything Travis did.
That was a freak accident because he's doing the right thing to Joe.
That doesn't mapping his hand up.
You're right.
No,
listen,
I agree with now if he did it and his finger at in his shorts and he's like,
fuck,
give him a second limb.
Figure out if he wants Canadian.
Here's a question.
Offensive move.
The hundred percent is the fish fingers.
His name is breaking the face,
breaking it or the more different than people in your arm,
your shoulder,
your neck.
But we have some weird sort of distinction.
Right?
Which is why you can say time out for that,
but you can't say timeout if you get hit in the nose.
That's right.
You can't,
if you're ever doing crew for there,
no fucking timeouts.
And when the afternoon was like,
that's ridiculous.
Why is that?
Brought that up to the post fight interview.
I was really clear like you were well within your rights to go after him.
Correct.
That was inside the rules for their audience and for let's just be cool about
it.
Okay,
your finger got caught.
I don't fucking want you to die,
but that's there's millions of dollars.
It's like come on,
but hold on a second.
Test Freddy's got a good point to the audience wants it to go on.
Like we were like we'd pay and it's not like Anderson,
so big deals and,
and for that one guy only,
it only makes sense for the guy that threw the punch.
That's the only guy that didn't make sense inflicted
but nobody,
nobody's trying to break fingers with punches.
If that was part of the sport,
you gotta practice prick fingers.
It's not illegal.
Let me knock out some walls here.
It's not illegal to
give Joe Rogan.
Let me knock down some walls here.
You're both right.
Yeah is absolutely.
Listen,
it's absolutely
and the Phi.
It's absolutely an injury caused by someone executing a technique.
But wouldn't you like to fight to keep going?
Just tore.
Would you like to say Matt,
would you like,
would you like Cain Velasquez or excuse me a for BC we're doing to win on
technical knockout due to a fingerprint break.
Doesn't matter.
I agree.
I agree with the answer.
I agree with you,
but I'm not saying guys within the rules.
I'm saying what do you want to see?
Let me knock some walls down.
Let me
wrap this shit up.
You got to stop talking over each eye and it's brutal.
But I'm Brown.
I'm the wise one.
Let me wrap this up guys.
Okay,
let me,
let me cork it up.
Quote some from the Washington parents.
Hold on.
No,
it's fair to say.
It's fair to say you'll know it when you see it.
Yes.
Right.
And it's up to you.
There's distractions in life.
There's discretion.
No,
when you see it and leave it up to the fighters,
leave it up to the ref.
You'll know it when you see it.
It's going to be a case by case basis.
Just one.
Just one Brendan in one.
There's just choices.
There's,
you have to,
there's a reason every situation's different,
but they also,
you don't know what happened to your finger.
I mean he just got cracked.
He doesn't know what happened.
He might thought he might've thought his finger cause it wasn't working right.
Was tied up in his glove.
What does it look at it?
I don't think Verdomme is wrong.
I think for dooms 100% right.
But I think there's a moment of confusion.
It's not like Travis got head kicked and was confused cause you've got almost
knocked out.
I think when his finger was fucked up,
he didn't necessarily know what was going on.
Yeah,
I think we have split second.
Whether or not that's true.
I don't know.
Only he knows,
but I'm saying there's a total possibility.
So I'm sure you get your finger smashed.
Mediator Joe's,
right?
No,
the whole thing.
I tried to look at the whole thing.
I am,
I'm saying even if he was like,
oh shit,
my fingers broke.
I'm looking like,
Damn.
Is that bro?
You all right bro.
All right,
let's keep going on the street.
What would you do?
It broke your fucking finger when it comes to a head kick to finish it off
because we have millions of dollars on the line yet.
Not Angry.
No,
no,
no.
I agree.
You're right.
You're right to no,
it's,
I agree this and here's a thing.
Then I argue with the finger,
I,
Hey,
here's your coach.
I'm leading.
I'm literally not even arguing with you because I see your point 100% but I also
saw you are to Brendan and I see even if,
but I also as a person who's greedy when I'm at home,
I want to see them keep fighting.
I'm with you.
You're right.
I'm greedy.
You know what?
I'm a fan of Fabrizio and I would like to see him win.
But there's,
there's a feeling that I get from someone winning by a broken finger that I
don't like.
Correct.
I liked the feeling furbish you'll want a clear decision because shit out of
him,
I promise.
Brendan's are like,
yeah,
he want his shit broken.
Finger broken.
Here's a better question.
Here's a better question cause it's an illegal move.
How much of an effect should I poke B because I really feel like,
I think not only does it change the game,
like mitre own versus Travis Browne.
Here's a case where the foul went and Travis has favor.
When when he poked uh,
Mitrione and stated the permission to by the grace and he did it twice.
It was two IPOs.
Yeah.
And then you know Mitch reone who was winning the fight then goes to losing the
fight.
Yeah.
It's a significant factor.
Nice.
Almost.
It's almost so significant that if you're marginally impaired from it,
you might want to stop the fight.
I agree.
How do you feel?
So it's just crazy because you're in the moment.
It's such a difficult like rational decision to make.
But if you're fucked up and you could barely see out of one eye,
you're like,
no,
I want to keep going.
I want to,
so you've been poked in the eye.
How terrible for that bitch recover those Tuesday and some guys never come back
from that is well that was a kick.
I believe any,
any eye injury could be like [inaudible] is a full third possibility that that
could design some kind of like fighting goggle thing.
Is that a possibility?
It would have to look up to protect the ice.
Yeah.
When you guys are getting poked,
the only way you could do it is if you came up with some sort of adhesive,
like some crazy,
crazy glue shit that you could stick this fucking thing to your face where it's
impossible to pull it off for all those are the only way.
But it would have to like literally almost be like cups that covered your eyes
but were like glued in your head.
And then afterwards they put some solvent on it,
but then we would find out five years later that fucking people are dying from
cancer brain.
You guys are soaking them in testosterone and shit.
Planet of the apes when they make you dirty days to have a chemical that they
would make your,
your,
uh,
you,
you know your [inaudible] Sandy.
Yes.
The movie with Mark Walberg
know that they found the stuff that they used was a chemical that doesn't listen
to Hank.
Can we please guys as Ofso MMA fan,
we actually watched this fight.
Don't fight.
Don't fight Jorge Mosbey doll versus Chase Shaka.
Fuck yes.
Oh,
he's a mosfet lik great.
Paul shorts,
a great striker.
He's,
it's a short humans.
Kimbo Kimbo but I gotta tell you,
man,
Jake Ellenberger coming off of that Kao of map brow,
like he was on the death doorstop.
Dude,
he had to beg for his job.
He had a bag for his job and he said,
please just give me one more fight.
And they go,
okay,
Matt Brown.
He was like,
oh my God,
I can't believe this.
Hey Kid.
He's like,
I'll take it.
And he went out there and stop Matt Brown and one round his man whose manager
went,
come on Joe,
give someone else.
And Joseph said,
fuck it.
Then you're cutting like,
no,
no.
We'll take it.
How do you know nick curse?
How does that get out?
How does shit like that?
Not say that.
Let's not say that.
Let's say really weakened action of gossip and Innuendo.
Not Ellenberger got Ellenberger in this
Washington like justify voting for chicken.
All due respect to my spin on,
because Austin,
when I Fuck Jake,
I love Jake.
Jake Ellenberger is a bow hunter.
Come on,
just going to be a left wing MMA and then a right wing Nma,
and they're going to get into their personalities in their lives.
What?
Right when he's going to win,
it's going to be a real problem.
Right.
We need to meet with the sports,
the guys who have the money that when a lot are going to be right.
Where he,
fuck.
Yeah.
Helen.
Dot.
Ellenberg doesn't support Nafta.
Made MMA.
Yeah,
it'd be hilarious.
Treaty of a massive dollar had Hashtag I'm with her on his Twitter account for
four hours.
We have screenshots and Democrats.
It's red and blue in the future.
Red Fox,
Democrat,
and it has to be that way.
Jake has more power check.
No,
not mosfet.
Donkin cracked my phone will get knocked down.
It's like,
oh dude.
Left Hook.
They play this gas for all can cracked it.
He's the first guy to knock out Eve Edwards at MMA.
He had kicked Eve Edwards back in.
That's hard.
That was back in Bodog fight.
I would have never pegged mass of the dog for a republic.
Oh,
good.
Glad body
that hurt him.
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck.
Oh,
he's in big trouble.
Trouble.
It's over,
son.
Oh,
he's getting dead.
that's it.
Oh,
herb dean went to ask first he went asked towards him hips towards him.
It's going to stop us.
Was the stay Dan.
That's what he tells him.
This Jake is talking about the check come back.
He's not going to in here.
You don't know.
Well,
no,
not stopping it or been doing a great job.
She made the ask move
to see the ass must be starving.
Such a monster that shows you how good herb dean is.
That shows you right there how he knows his shit.
Yes ass look at this,
but Mazda doll has got pinned up against the cage.
Ellenberger has got to get some space.
There you go.
Damn.
Circle left circle.
Lap shake has done a boxing bag these up.
Hey,
well Jake still possesses that crazy fast twitch muscle fiber.
So if he can connect,
he can crack you.
Well,
the last thing he goes,
Powell.
Jake's always had power,
but when you get hurt,
you always start reaching for that cause you know you're not going to play like
a points game from here on out cause you're diminished.
So you've got a few like significant rounds in your chamber.
It's just a matter of how long it's going to take.
Jake Ellenberger right now to recover.
But here's the thing,
if he's been trained with curse on,
I think he has for this fight.
I know he asked for this fight.
As a matter of fact,
it's been at kings to training with nick.
Curse on is a big thing,
man.
Nickerson.
Who was that?
MARV Marinovich disciple.
That guy's a wizard man.
He knows off fuck load about strength and conditioning and getting guys ready
for fights both physically and mentally.
And I think he helped Ellenberger a lot would giving them the confidence with
being in that insane shape to get ready for Matt Brown.
There's,
there's no coach on the planet and go,
Hey,
you're gonna get fucked up the first minute and then we can work on that.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
There's no conditioning for that,
right?
You're right.
There's nothing you got to the x factor,
but it's also like Ellenberger is a real veteran now and he's experienced those
disappointing defeats.
He's been in those super highlight knockouts like the map route fight like
shields fight.
He's composed after taking a look at how compelling elements more legit and war
and the best of all,
Hillary loves them.
Do you know Ellen Bird?
Oh Shit.
The fuck up.
It's a joke.
I know that Ellenberger knocked out palae Landy with one punch.
Yes.
That was back in the Disney Belfour.
Oh no,
it wasn't.
I don't think it was a belt.
We're fighting.
Is that right?
And he took it on.
She was you.
That's a good boxer.
He was some Jake Ellenberger oh one with the wheelchair left kick to the body.
Oh.
Oh Ellen.
Berta slipped and broke his foot toe stuck in that cage.
You should let him recover.
What happened?
He,
I think he broke his foot and ankle.
You can the cage.
What do you do at this point?
No,
this is hilarious guys.
We're seeing exactly what we saw
as pregnant is going to say fuck him.
He said,
is this fight stopped?
Is this fight stopped?
John Joe Joe's going to say,
hey,
give the guy a little chance to your side.
That's the problem.
Eddie,
I'd haven't picked aside.
I'm on both of your sides.
Say What my side was,
but then we did before when we were talking about the finger side,
at this point he was getting fucked up,
so
he was already getting Johnny and let's find out what the hell happened here.
Ellenberger prints like a psychic throws the kick.
He slides in Tacos.
Boom.
I get it.
I go,
stop is snapped his foot.
Let me tell me what you think.
If I'm Mazda doll,
I wail away exactly like he did and when the fight exactly like he did was too
much riding on.
Dude,
you're so fucking mean.
Okay,
well the fights over it is over.
The fight is over.
I see that your homeboy,
this is what I feel like.
This is my take on this.
This is a great fight.
Have Fun fight that ended with a freak accident.
The mosfet all got some great shots.
Sullenberger looked like he was staying calm,
but if you had to go to decision off of the injury,
you had got to give it to Moscow.
Moscow was putting it to them.
My hospital had him in a lot of trouble,
like clue.
There's slides in his toe,
wet right in there and it's,
oh,
he's just snapped his toe back row.
No,
no,
no.
You're so ruthless as a favor because I'm nosy,
lighter.
You mark them as fast,
your kid.
Hey guys,
let's look at it this way.
As a pres,
as people that love the sport,
maybe we should redesign the bottom of the cage.
Yes,
it may be down for that,
but it's not his fault.
It's not his fault.
This guy caught in the fence.
Let me ask you this game.
Do you think that that part of the game ball still gets mad at you?
You moved to the left and he fucking slides in and he gets his foot.
Let me ask you this.
As a person who's fought in the octagon,
is there an argument for extending the lip a little bit?
So instead of Tuck it,
Tuck it up.
We'd be putting in a bar fish.
How many would you could only have to go up a few inches and it would remove the
problem of the edge move,
but you wouldn't be able to use,
you know that take down a fence.
So this guys against the cage,
take your heels in twice.
Well that's Kinda cheap too,
isn't it?
That body that caught oh
well that would help everybody then everyone like having a little bit of a,
let's talk about that.
Having a little bit of fabric pulled it through and up and connect it to the
cage.
That would be a good thing.
So he slipped in there.
Oh my God.
It's awful fucking told.
He's getting punched in the head and he's still trying to get his phone up.
They don't cut them.
Give them one more.
It's flipped.
That kind of gave him 100% man.
He just knocked out Matt Brown and he has his controversial,
uh,
injury.
Uh,
don't,
we'll go by 100% here's the problem with the controversial injury.
Mazda doll is the one who got robbed here cause Mosfet Woodall was putting it to
him before that he still gets,
he gets,
he won,
they won.
But if it was a draw like dope,
he's injured both guys.
I feel like both guys robbed got robbed a little bit and doesn't burn.
Got Robbed and potential for a comeback.
Correct.
Justice was done because Mazda Bell who was winning and he still gets his wind
bonus and Jake got you.
It's not a happy justice.
It's not justice.
It makes them feel cheer and sewing.
It feels not chair.
Who feels not changing?
There'll be no singing.
Nope.
Zero but yeah,
I agree with that.
I think you're right.
When you and Eddie were like going at it back and forth,
I'm on both of your sides.
I come and get him.
I get it.
Finger break.
It's a break.
It's through due to an attack.
Look,
honestly,
anytime you feel like you,
maybe you should stop the fight.
You should stop the fight like almost every time for something like that.
It should you let a guy go.
If you can't see it all,
whatever's right eye is 50 seconds left in the round,
50 seconds.
It's for the title.
The guys,
the champion,
he can't see.
He says he's fine.
What do you do?
Stop at Brendan.
It's a good question because sometimes guys go out and they win that case by
case.
It's case by case.
It's hard,
man.
It is not easy.
It's not easy,
easy.
I'm saying there's a fight and you're in there and you know what the magnitude
of that wind will do for your career and get you to next level and you're
punching and goes,
damn dog you,
you got me in the eye.
You're all about in the winter.
You're like,
what?
No,
no Eddie,
you don't.
You're a winner as motherfucker something with that comment.
You're right.
Look you right in that,
that you know that might be part of the problem,
right?
Like a killer instinct in the minutes it looks like,
I know what you're saying.
Like it's not just the ethics of winning or losing or under the fair here get a
win and fighting,
get out bonus and yeah.
Is that an issue?
Is when bonuses are when bonuses an issue.
And did they ever exist in boxing before MMA started adopting them in boxing?
I don't think so.
Nobody's going to watch boxing.
That's not true.
Um,
I don't think so.
I don't think they are.
No.
I think boxers they fight for a purse.
Yes.
And then it's a flat fee.
The flat fee.
And then you got your paper if you bust.
Is there an argument that when bonuses make the fights more exciting?
Uh,
I don't know if you need them,
like,
cause cause people,
I mean obviously they're aware of women dentists,
but no one's like,
God,
I gotta make this aside and I'm going to go do this because hopefully I get the
wind bonus.
Here's Tony Ferguson.
Does
he,
that's his style.
That's his style.
He does.
He goes after him.
Eddie,
he tell you what,
there's wind boats or not.
He's going to fight like that.
That's totally,
that's in his blood.
Let me ask you this question.
He wants to get that money.
No,
but friends like that,
he's a fucking and seen him train six hours straight.
Um,
you know when people say,
Oh,
I tried eight hours straight,
I trained seven hours and you're like,
okay,
you're taking all these breaks I seen that day.
He was trained at all God Damn Day and in big bear in altitude mass,
six hours,
dude,
hanging out with Tony Marx in big bear made me feel like a fucking little mouse.
Like Holy Shit.
Not only where is that?
They thought it was gonna be an Anaheim,
but they,
they,
they were like,
oh,
we're going to Manheim light.
Remember they took,
they pulled the paper.
You from Manheim,
is it Paul?
The hundred percent.
Yes.
They canceled Anaheim.
It.
When did it get cancelled today?
Two days.
Can I have it?
So is that official Tony and Khabib?
It was supposed to be on the anum 800 cars
schedule it.
But that's the fight.
Fight,
fight,
fight
Conor and wants to take some time off.
He's about to have his first child.
Totally get it.
Tarnished fight is with WWE and Ari Emanuel.
Tony keep saying that and it sounds like God damn mantra.
It's like Donald Trump KKK.
How good that's going to be anti gay
is real fight is with Ari menu because it's true.
The placard.
It's true though.
Whoa.
Dan's got
negotiation room.
Maybe they're in a good place.
Who's his girl?
Well,
even if they're in a good place,
that's the fight.
You're a little bit of a gossiper.
He like it
little bit,
but hey,
but
Robert Dinero was good fellas.
Guys out
little bet little bars when he says you were a
little bit,
go get your shine box.
That's a great stabs him in the neck to the pen.
Great team.
Um,
so yeah,
but I'm not wrong because when Conor goes,
and I still have some inside info,
but when we caught him,
but when Conor goes,
when Conor goes,
I need a portion of the company now,
I'm not finding,
if you give me that,
who's his battle with Tony Ferguson?
It could be they don't,
they have no ownership of that.
They don't have control of that.
Here's why it's foolish to get a portion of the company because he,
by very nature of his dynamic being and presence makes the paper views that he's
on spectacular.
He doesn't elevate the other paper views.
So when he's there is,
he was saying,
should you get a percentage of the paper views?
Absolutely does.
He does.
He should get a percentage of the company.
You would have to prove that you're making the company bigger.
No,
you're not.
You're making yourself bigger.
And he is.
He's by,
in my opinion,
the most famous,
but by four fights that he draws for,
he will get compensated for an extraordinary manner.
The idea,
the idea of him,
him being an owner of the entire company based on what he's able to do in his
own individual paper views is that would be foolhardy.
But what about,
what about mark time,
obviously not a businessman,
but just what about Conor McGregor?
Like fucking he doesn't get paid paid Affleck and like he can be listened to
more in the country.
Why did it not get pulled?
Because it didn't have a fucking title fight.
What does that mean?
That the UFC without gigantic stars like Conor McGregor or Ronda Rousey or John
Jones or Petterson Holloway without the killers nobody wants to watch.
Correct.
Should be,
and I want to pay for pain killers,
part of guests,
superstars make the company that you can have some fights and colors by you
fights.
You can have some fights that are paper view fights without without world
champions on it.
It is totally possible if you had a bunch of Cowboy Matt Brown type fights on
and you know just a bunch of them and none of them for the world title.
You're telling me what new watch you tell me when you watch.
He will heal.
Well,
Romero versus a Luke Rockhold a drawl.
You tell me you would watch that.
I'm not talking to
a socialist and unions and shit.
Yeah,
you fucking union.
Cause I left winger.
Daddy knows what's up.
Info wars.
Oh Jordan,
me and versus a meal.
Meek.
That's a good fucking join.
Kt Kelvin Jordan Meehan on Cyborg.
The male Cyborg in Strikeforce landed one of the most devastating fucking elbow
combinations to put outside Borg and Amil Meek is a guy who beat up to keen
mule.
He knocked out to Kenya when he first got kicked out of the UFC.
When who's smart?
Paul Horez got kicked out of the UFC.
He fought this mad viking and meal meek.
He'd beat the fuck out of him.
He killed him in the first round.
What's Turkeys Code?
He keeps hitting KOD cause he had been pictures legs off and Emma and Jujitsu.
He fought Gary Cohn.
Tonin in a straight up traditional went to draw.
But Gary Tonin was dominating.
Gary.
Tony was attacking him way more than he was tapped.
How scary to Keno was for a while.
And here's the thing,
Gary Tonin is maybe 30 pounds lighter than I am.
No Bush won best in the world.
I'm just saying and crass Chino was Paula Harris.
Motherfuckers were terrified.
You know why I was fascinated about that fight was not just the Gary tone as a
motherfucker,
but that John Donahoe and I had this conversation about the entrances that uh,
Tokyo uses,
you know,
and I'm like the entrance is how he,
how he establishes the entrance into his techniques that he has like some pretty
obvious entrances.
He's like,
he's kind of basic in the way he approaches leg locks and like his,
his take was that they would always be like one step ahead of them.
Like I mentioned,
the strength would run out and recommend cause you,
you can see it coming so you know how to stop it.
That's how high level and sophisticated that whole Eddie Cummings Yup.
Hands up.
Well it's John Danaher is a big part of it.
Oh yeah.
But he was also,
there's a ton of guys,
Dean lister contributed to that in a big way because he came over there.
There's a,
there's a lot of leg lock knowledge that came out of there,
but even so,
g o still one knee behind last night through respect.
It was sent to jail.
Dude,
I like the way you brought that down and did bring it back and you
tell everybody,
give it a name drop.
Tell stories.
The most feared leg rocker she Omani.
He says the most fear,
the freak show I think is the best Lego.
I call.
I call him Eddie leg lock Cummings.
Well I do.
She probably taught,
stop talking.
You guys be shut off for a moment.
I'll wrap it up.
I'll bring it.
I'll bring it back.
Keep calling.
Who's calling?
I don't know.
Don't fight it.
This hasn't gone.
It's so Hutto Benevidez coming up.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
Most of Eddie Cummins fights an n Ebi and just me as just the Jujitsu guy
watching him like right there on top of it.
I can't fucking believe it,
man.
Eddie Cummins as just mow in through fucking everybody.
The whole damn her crew,
Gary,
Tony and Gordon Ryan,
the fucking everybody up with those leg box manic.
They got a super sophisticated,
highly complex leg lock system and,
and you know,
once Ebi,
uh,
came out,
that's when it was exposed and me as a teacher,
I thought,
fuck,
I thought I was already a leg lock friendly enough.
I had a bunch of leg lock wizards all over the association there were there
everyone I thought,
oh,
I'm totally open on leg locks.
Me Personally,
I'm not heavy into heel hooks,
but man,
I love the fact that every class has like three heel hook fucking just dudes
that are obsessed with it.
And,
but that wasn't enough once Abi came,
I'm like,
that wasn't enough liquid.
These guys,
when you obsess with leg locks in the system and every possibility in every
counter and the way Danaher's put that system together,
man,
now I realized right away I got to get fucking mid evil with this shit.
So we did over the last couple of years and
cause he feel to feel like you're competing a little bit with John or 100% I
love that 100% yes,
there's that.
There's an IB,
j j f crew,
you know the like the people,
the fans and the,
and,
and the,
the competitors.
There's the Danaher crew and they're like,
they're like Conor Mcgregor,
you know,
cause like Gordon Ryan's kind of outspoken and you know,
he's like wearing a crown everywhere he goes.
And Gary Tone and he's like,
he's,
he's there were all super cool man.
And then Eddie come and just like the coolest motherfucker ever.
Eddie come astrophysicists.
Cool ass dude.
I never just,
all those guys are awesome man.
And I would Danaher's done with that leg lock system.
Did he just,
so he took what Dean lists or showed him dean lister came down in the late
nineties and at Hanzo school and dropped some heel hook knowledge on Danaher and
Danner just systemize that shit.
Blew it the fuck up.
And if you're not paying it,
paying attention to the Jujitsu world and the sub only movement,
the Danaher Death Squad,
Eddie Cummings,
uh,
Gordon,
Ryan,
Gary Tonin,
even uh,
Gordon Ryan's brother,
Nicky Ron,
they got there,
they got this leg lock system that no one can fuck with their bowling through
our distributor bar districts mowing through every,
everybody
that grill artistry.
Yeah.
You feel it.
You feel like that that's what did you feel like you were,
at what point when you were rolling Jujitsu,
did you feel like it became more art than sport in that you were improvising as
you went along in that everything was a reaction.
Everything was sort of predicated by your mindset,
your mood,
uh,
of that day,
what that person was doing and do what the mood of the day that I could tell it
had to do with it just had to do with how many times can you do a movement and,
and train your body,
your body at whatever you do,
tell became backs,
basketball,
whatever you do.
If you do it over and over and over again.
If you're working in a factory and you got a job or you're doing something,
the more you do it,
whatever it is,
putting this contraption here,
you're going to be so fucking good at it.
Pam,
your body is,
will master anything you tell it to do a thousand times,
right.
So it becomes a language you're flowing in that you're,
that you know,
physically that you know.
Uh,
uh,
so it's like in the
a building fucking blocks,
the factory work and whatever,
it's all about numbers.
It's just practice makes perfect.
It's just how the more you do what your body will end up doing it magically and
you'd have to just kind of like executive produce things and your body just
doesn't magically like,
like uh,
like tying your shoes,
like playing violin when you're shredding on violin or a piano or whatever type
Brian or type that shit typing.
When you type it,
you just sort of thinking like now I've been typing for so many years and not,
I'm not perfect match a fuck up.
But when I type,
when I'm in the groove,
yeah.
I'm just looking at the screen of thinking and then the words just start,
my fingers start moving.
It's weird you send it because I was typing and my father said,
Jesus Christ,
you type fast,
and it didn't even dawn on me.
I was like,
Huh.
Well that's what Dan has done.
We learned that's what they've done.
They've gotten a system down and they,
what happened,
Jim,
they understand practice makes perfect.
Right.
And they understand that perfect practice makes perfect.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's even better.
No,
I love that about life.
I love that about the idea that you can master something that you definitely
can.
Yeah.
I mean you get better at anything.
You put your time too.
If you don't get perfect,
it's so worthwhile.
Does never ever endeavoring down that road that the reaching for it is,
is the whole lesson,
right?
Yeah.
You'll have milestones.
Yes.
But the through those milestones,
the the most important things,
you'd just enjoying the process and then one day you wake up and you realize,
Whoa,
we look at or I could do.
Are you always learning what you do through?
Are you,
do you feel like you're kind of over it all?
Man,
everybody.
Everybody learns for what we're talking about right now with what Danaher's
dealt with the leg lock system and what they've done with and that you're just
completely dominate that.
Bringing it back to the GL Martinez wind last night he beat Geo or he beat Eddie
Cummings in the finals at Ebi 10 last night.
I was just in Mexico City.
It was,
what'd you give it back?
Yeti nuts this morning.
Damn jetlag or no dude,
it was just,
that was no jet lag about to get turnt up in Austin this weekend.
What's was gone this week?
I think we hate each other,
but were commentating together.
Why did they think people are just silly?
So you know what,
like this conversation that happened in the beginning of this podcast when
everybody went crazy.
Yeah.
We're like the best trends.
I don't feel bad about it.
You guys don't feel bad about it.
I'm a little bit,
but here's the
thing,
man,
is that thing that like people have to understand you.
You're allowed to disagree about shit and still be cool.
You could be both.
Well not only that,
you don't have to disagree with something and go,
you're cause you're a fucking retard.
That's why every fucking look at is Eddie is Eddie wants to solve a problem and
Eddie like when I think
we're going to go deep into the router.
No,
not doing that.
I'm not doing that.
No.
Listen everyone.
Listen.
What I'm saying is that when somebody is passionate and cares about the world
and wants a world to be a better place like he does,
that's where it's coming on the same team.
That's where it,
yeah.
So when you know that,
when you know that he's genuinely a good person through his fucking core,
which I know that about him,
like Eddie seven different point of view.
I've texted Eddie about,
but there's no way.
There's no way I'm going to look at Eddie is like that.
I can't do that.
What do I said?
You bought it online?
I've always had like a bottom line.
Is this the bottom line is I think they are fucking us,
right?
Oh,
it's,
that's what I think.
They are fucking and you meet everyone.
Everyone's over back in jail.
Shit.
Goddammit.
Told you what you,
but let's say man,
all then you've known him.
Me.
I
don't think you're fucking me.
So if I thought there were fucking hell would hate you.
I'm trying to convince you.
Right?
Count How many times you're trying to get me right.
Can you,
how many labels trained with Eddie Bravo.
Zero.
You guys don't know underground school motherfucker.
I know him better than you.
Just trying to lead you out of the dark lands online Jujitsu class,
which is secret double.
How many times are trained the dark one,
right?
Even put a number to ask Eddie.
Eddie,
am I right on this?
They're fucking him.
Oh Dude.
And he gives me private fucking him underground
are fucking him.
Bullying.
When do you start working for Fox News?
Got Dan and Joe Journalist.
Oh my God,
you're
hire this one.
I want to say Donald Trump can be soldier
for Donald Trump.
I have a message for Donald Trump.
Donald,
while you're in office,
I want you to abandon the Republican Party and joined the Freak Party.
We will let you do whatever you want.
Be Whoever you are.
Let's just try to be nice to each other.
Let's cut the shit loose,
man.
Just cut loose,
They offered you $100,000 a year,
Brian Cowen,
when your tastes on it.
I'm telling you,
they're right on the pilot as Brendan,
his brother,
one of my favorite people in the world.
He's sending me and sending me all kinds.
There are,
hey,
listen,
let's not,
let's not look.
It's not talking about
I say it.
He's the one who started this thing.
I do want to to really good at killing people like Jujitsu style gets really
good at playing games,
gets really good at arguments.
It doesn't want to get in before killer.
He gave you an out and you want to keep going and you like the little saying,
think the cat's going to kill them.
All I'm saying is before the night's over,
I need to know what pizza gate is not doing this.
No Camera Pizza,
pizza gate off camera Hashtag pizza gate.
Hey listen,
trust me.
You don't want to know this is like,
this is murder shit.
You'll get murdered and you're talking about this shit.
This is amazing.
Fight coming up.
Absolutely.
To get Merck.
You know what I thought?
I thought you know what?
I think the meaning of life pizza is the meaning of life is there's fucking
scumbags everywhere.
Tried to maneuver around them and try to keep your family and you can also can't
stop thinking about things.
Just thinking about MMA.
Pizza Gate is Mark Henry Pizza say fluff to fix a place.
Teachers,
I'm going to end.
I'm going to end it with,
if you all don't watch constituency of silence on Youtube before you get into
pizza gate first,
the conspiracy of silence,
then get into pizza gate in an all.
Makes Sense.
Okay,
that's it.
So Huda,
amazing fight to Mexico.
Shannon Brown,
they talked a lot of shit.
Give me some volume show.
I worked for the company back to Youtube.
Gimme some volume.
I want to hear what's going on,
man.
Here we go.
My prediction Benevidez wins.
Gets a little more Jewish.
Short killers.
Short killers right here.
Here we go.
Henry is a bad bout of is a good fight.
He won a bet.
Eddie quick.
Oh,
I got 100% I have joy paces.
Oh Jesus Christ.
They are fucking swinging and he blah.
Flow.
All right.
How about dinner in Austin for God's sakes?
Oh my God.
Oh,
oh no,
no,
no.
I'm down.
I'm down with dinner.
No,
no,
forget it now.
No,
no boys.
Boys,
please bet no.
Can I bet for some money?
Yes.
You,
Britain,
France
and he a hundred I'm just as bad.
We're in.
We're when we got action.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I just want everyone to know that I'm not betting on anybody.
That Emilia backer.
Yeah.
You're giving them a Lennon.
Why you have so much?
Oh,
and chose a friend of mine,
so of course it would.
It would go for him was a friend of yours because Joe's a friend of mine.
Oh,
well Joe Benevidez is a friend of mine as well.
I looked and I love so who to?
Oh,
nut kick.
that's some honor right there.
Respect to that.
Right?
It's different.
He understood the nutcase.
Yes,
you're right.
It's illegal.
Right.
Punches to the finger.
Not Illegal,
but he recognized it was correct.
Not kicked a little different as a respect thing,
man.
There's,
that's a bad thing when you see a guy.
No,
he kicked the dude in the nuts and then go
was dead on.
That's going to be honest.
A little bit more taint than balls still hurts though still,
and she gets the Obama that sad.
No,
I'm not an apologist.
I'm not a neighbor list.
I'm not a nut shot now eve Levine and let you get your ass whooped.
Now he's been known to let it go.
Oh,
well he's no Steve Gaudy,
but yeah,
he'll let you tap for a little bit.
[inaudible]
my favorite.
I love you.
Got To let anything happen.
Hey,
it must have gotten stuck and rough and texts me.
I'll fucking watch it anywhere.
Maurice was taking his fingers into Jake,
Jake shields eyes and massive guy just sat there.
Maza got all the best highlights or Mazda honey fights.
You ever notice that?
Yeah.
Well,
how bout when Mazda Gotti was reffing Brock Lesnar versus Frank Mir?
Almost a separated his hips from his legs,
tapping like Taylor hit him in the Dick Again,
Roy.
He's a no nonsense,
no bullshit aside,
joking around.
I love eve.
He's a no nonsense guy.
If he thinks that that is a two in a row,
he will take a point and here's the argument,
right?
If it was unintentional,
should you take a point?
Well,
here's the problem.
The damage done.
Oh,
Benevidez is legit as far as like it diminishes him.
So that is worth more than a point on his,
his potential performance.
Same with an eye poke.
Yeah,
got to get my books even worse.
I poke right away.
Should be a point taken away.
I think you're 100% correct.
It changes the magnitude of the fight.
I agree with him.
100% agreed with him.
100% Eddie Bravo thinks that Brian count is a bar.
I think he's gotten so drunk.
He's just holding as Gladys out to Brian.
Callan is not even looking at him.
Shab who's a loving that point.
You've got to pull out
Washington Post for a driver.
I got it.
Yeah.
Mantra.
You can throw those kicks like that.
You can't and you're not disciplined enough.
You can't throw the kicks.
They're moving targets.
Taekwondo in 10th grade.
Say Stop It.
Those kids moved a little too tiny
quiet in 10th grade.
I'm just picturing guys named Chad with no fucking facial hair at this balance
here,
man.
I said switches.
Dances with no fucking plan for the fences.
Random colored belt.
Oh,
this fight is awesome.
Bra.
Who knows?
Walking him down pissed because his last fight off suitors.
Demetrius Johnson got annihilated.
So these also probably pissed because he's lost one point already in this first
round,
so he's got a wind.
Significantly.
Brian would be a draw because if he's with one point he's been winning the whole
fight less Benevidez does something strong and which he'll when it,
oh crap,
but you know what man?
Sometimes some people take a point away.
They automatically say,
well that guy is losing the fight now.
Like it's almost like a psychological thing.
The judges are tough man by tough.
Some of them,
some of them are not good.
No,
Some of them definitely not good.
Let me ask you this.
What did you think of the Tyron Woodley Wonderboy fight?
Have you watched that fight?
I called it a judge.
I think you're right.
I think you were Brian,
what I say to you before,
before they came out,
when he was my,
my thinking,
I think it's only a draw because we look at fights wrong.
I think Woodley one because he did a way more way more damage,
way more knocked them down.
You're the fight.
How about that kid he had,
he had moments of total dominance like that first round when he got on top of
it.
There was never a point where Wonderboy was running the fight and it was a vat
should be.
There should be like a point aspect to that.
I agree with you.
You're right.
Correct.
I used to this moments where you're like maybe like you land a jab and he lands
a leg kick and what's better and what's worse.
And there's a debatable moment.
But when Woodley took him down and beat him up with the first round and smashes
nose open,
that was a significant and the guilty.
How about the punches that led to the Guillotine?
Yes.
It had him hurt.
Almost had him finished.
So he made a mistake going for the guilty.
He probably did fine.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
Let's watch this fight.
You Fuck No.
But to Joe's point is my hand right now,
right?
I won the fight in fight aspects.
He won the fight.
Some shit
that happened that he's right and he's right.
You're both right.
And any problems,
the voice of reason who to fucking ever thought these guys are having 15 bands.
That's why for now,
really way one third and they're amazing.
But there was a bed shut the fuck Yo.
I mean Brandon got dammit.
You fucking giant.
Giant privilege.
The viewers would agree with me.
He left writing critically different male privilege and giant privilege.
You're a disgusting humans.
There's nothing bad ever happened to him.
He's never had any bad.
You have four thirsty blues of white privilege.
You have big Dick Privilege,
podcasts,
privilege.
It's got it all.
You're the son of a bitch.
I knew that John Privilege so stupid.
Son of a bitch.
He's like a fucking son of a bitch.
Shut the 10 years.
Move out of the way out of a bitch.
Fuck her.
There's going to be that,
that one night,
Brian,
when he can't follow them.
I know you son of a bitch.
I know it was paid out how to be funny than me.
They're funnier with your fat garden hose dangling out of the inside of your
jeans.
What the fuck is that?
How about you tuck that thing,
that bad boy and hide it from the children?
Do Your fucking job.
Put it away.
God,
the soccer away.
Did you guys see the road runner killed a rattlesnake?
I've shown everybody on own casting.
No,
I haven't seen it.
Roadrunners,
fucking kill and eat rattlesnakes.
Fuck,
that's bird.
Yeah.
You look at a road runner rattlesnake.
You would say,
well for sure the rattlesnakes are eating the road.
Runners
roadrunners,
eat watched.
It runs from the rattlesnake.
It incorrect.
The road runners hunting it.
Damn.
Oh is literally hunt.
Look at that dinosaur looks nothing like the cause.
They're up close.
When you're a close look at this shit.
The road one are so fast.
One C shop away.
Camera tricks.
Well look,
it's right there.
You didn't see that.
This is,
I looked it up after I saw this video.
It's a fact roadrunners.
He fucking say,
Oh shit.
Face and now look at this.
He smashes his head on the fucking rocks.
Help gangster.
This bird dude,
I got a new fingernails.
I got a new favorite animal.
Holy Shit.
He's just smashing that fucking head on the rocks.
Look at this wet to road runner to food.
He just,
that motherfucker,
he just
fucking snapped the whole fucking day.
Swallow the whole fuck.
Someone say he deep throated that rattlesnake should beds.
My guys fights back.
Gosh Dan,
to keep that.
Keep that Brian,
go for it.
Keep that left hand.
Right hand man.
A boy.
Jesus.
So who does winning?
Right?
So who to looks pissed.
I'm nursing him.
Fight with this much bad.
They've worked alongside each other for a long time and talked to a lot of shit
to each other.
Well Joe keeps swaying for that right hand counter.
Just lights a little off tonight.
He,
well he's probably been tagged a few times that first round and now he's looking
for that big right hand and get things back.
The reason I thought Joe would win this fight,
and I'm not saying he's not going to,
he does everything really well and pseudo does a few things.
Great.
So I thought Joe would kind of edge it out with just mixing it up,
but he's not doing that well.
So who always doing a stone where near the level of experience other than the
Johnson fight.
Seven fights.
Yeah,
I mean,
and Benevidez is fought Johnson a couple of times.
That,
how about that one?
When I,
God damn mighty mouse,
mighty mouse from mercy,
he worked both of these guys.
So who do I mean?
He said,
how many did he knock out joy Benevidez oh yeah.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He crushed him,
you know,
and then what he did this or Huda was pretty God damn impressive to some
amazing,
beautiful down to the technical kicks or knees rather to the body.
The morning time from the clench.
Jesus was perfect.
Did you hear what mighty mouse said before that fight?
They went,
well,
he is an Olympic gold medalist and rested.
He went,
there's 250 gold medalists.
There's one,
you know,
fucking world champion like this.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
Yup.
So legit love mighty mouse.
I've been singing mighty mouse is praises forever.
He's not by pound for pound number one.
Who's your pound for pound number one?
Jon Jones over Conor Mcgregor.
Yeah.
See,
but you can't say that,
but here's what I think.
When you look at John Jones,
I think Jon Jones,
uh,
ultimately it absolutely has a potential to be number one,
but he's been to inactive and the fight with OVN St Prue,
although Ovince Saint [inaudible],
it fills a very good fighter.
It's a very tough fight.
If you look at who has beaten over and Saint Pru and who,
you know how John Jones looked against [inaudible] one five,
right?
You can't tow entirely by,
but as of late,
he's been incredibly inactive.
Cla has been not change
when you mighty mouse has been active.
He's been spectacular.
But the thing is is we've seen mighty mouse lose.
We've never seen John Jones Lewis.
You're right.
God,
you guys are missing a great fight.
You're right.
But he's not fun.
And also what mighty mouse is,
he can he and make a mistake at punch with right hand.
There are 125 pounds.
They keep on,
keep on.
John Jones makes one mistake and [inaudible] he fell because classes,
I don't have a pound for pound number one.
That is.
It did as a good argument except for guys like John Lennon grew and knock guys
out with one punch and mighty mouse who knocked out Benevidez with one pot.
It's still different than it is.
A little bit.
205 pounds.
Your rosters,
you guys,
it's a little bit different.
He's a little bit,
have you forgotten about a guy named Anderson Silva?
Brian Callen coming in and fucking shut.
Shut it down.
What about gas pump?
The best ever.
Right now it's entirely possible to make the case of either fade or Anderson
Silva or mighty mouse.
I make the case chest pain.
Maybe if he didn't lose
his last STP,
fine,
but not for doing junior fight.
Anderson Silva who finished everybody.
It's arguable that for Jim's the best heavyweight of all time you can make
something.
That's what I'm arguing.
Not Pound from.
Sorry.
Heavyweight.
Yes.
Pound for pound.
John Mighty mouse.
Yeah,
you can put Connor up there.
Oh,
Anderson Connors and argument
on something that was,
don't you think he's the number one fighter of all time?
As far as like,
no.
I think finishing everybody think Gianna's with style.
The way he did.
What are we talking about here?
You know,
I don't know shit about stepping up.
Everybody know that.
I don't know shit about striking can visibly see when he's corner countering
with his,
with his left hand.
I could see that and I don't really see it with a lot of fighters.
I know.
I don't know shit,
but is that,
no,
you're right.
It like an amazing counterpart.
100% of that because I'm seeing like your,
as soon as someone throws he goes,
oh,
it's like just waiting for such a hundred percent clean.
It's so obvious.
It's so,
it's waiting for you.
As soon as you throw,
he's going to fucking spots.
Good.
Connor has this ability to slide back and counter with such incredible
precision.
He's just got it.
It's beautiful.
Joe,
don't you get a full precision to,
it's the techniques.
Perfect.
He plants it right on your chin.
He's super accurate.
He's so fast.
You get surprised.
You don't.
You think his strength is to is he's had some sort of skill where he can
predetermine what you're going to do.
You know what I'm saying?
Like really seen it.
We've never really seen a lot of understanding of striking and movement.
How do you get,
how do you get that good time?
If you say,
I want to be,
if a guy comes to you and says,
Joe,
I'm going to dedicate my life to you.
I want me,
I want you to turn me into the ultimate counter.
I would say go to that fucking dude on his knees in front of Joseph Benevidez
Twitter.
Duane Ludwig about the counters.
Toad,
toad,
Duane Ludwig.
How about the fuck.
Just get the fastest ever fucking Caleb in the UFC from account.
Then you find writing the Canadian.
Yeah.
Um,
he had uh,
multiple colored here.
God,
why can't I remember his name?
I can't remember his fucking name either.
God does.
Joey had a twin brother.
What would you do?
No,
like actual sending me Duane Ludwig.
But what would like a drill you would come up with that you would take,
hey,
you got to do this shit every day.
Depending on where you're at.
Like skill wise,
like,
can you kick,
can you punch?
Should you not even bother kicking?
How much time do we have to work with you?
Like what are you going to do?
Like if you,
if you took a guy who like almost no kicks whatsoever,
you'd say,
okay,
let's,
let's forget the kicks,
but I want you to do is just check kicks.
We're gonna work on punches.
Can you throw elbows?
I don't want you off balance throwing kicks you your,
there's a lot of different things you would think of,
but when you see Connor's counters,
his counters are so precise.
You only get that through that 10,000 hour principle to work with someone yet
five years be obsessed and they ought to be genetically gifted because there's
certain punchers they just did not have that kind of snap to be counter guy.
It's like a guy like Matt Hamill who was a really powerful wrestler and a good
puncher and a good striker.
Ultimately later in his career,
he never had that.
But there's that fucking,
there's that fucking Tammy some bad have you don't.
But you know what I mean?
Got Good example.
Good example.
Cause he's a tough guy in a strong,
powerful resume.
Explosive.
Right,
right,
right.
Kind of accuracy that there's a bunch of guys you could say that you could put
in that category who were like really powerful grapplers who just weren't the
most lightning like strikers.
There's a,
there's a certain type of striking,
there's striking where you know that the guy has good technique and you know
that the guy pretty much understands where to be and where not to be and when to
be defensive,
when to be offensive.
That's like a well rounded Stryker.
And then there's guys like Roy Jones Jr.
There's every now and then you have these tank creeks.
But Roy Jones Jr was a weird one because Roy Jones Jr abandoned all of the
Orthodoxy of boxing.
I mean he kept his hands low,
barely threw jabs.
He threw a leaping left hook instead and he had ridiculous speed and power to
the point where nobody can fuck with it.
Met when he was in his prime.
Yeah.
Fuck he was so funny.
Did you watch the Kovalev Andre Ward?
Yes.
Tight man.
Terrible.
I watched it again.
I watched it again and uh,
I wanted to see if I was biased cause I thought the Kovalev won and I still
think you won.
Yeah.
I said why I didn't think you won by one much.
And I think Andre Ward did a really good job of holding his own,
but I just don't think there was enough convincing rounds where ward one in the
way that I think the rounds that Kovalev won.
I agree.
So I was like,
man,
I was watching my God,
I feel like Cola.
Definitely one.
But it was close.
And then when Letterman was like,
oh,
it's a complete blowout.
I'm like,
well I don't agree with that.
I don't think I'll j ward one but I don't think he got blown out.
No,
I think it was a one point for Kovalev and I think the reason why you can make
that is because I think that Andre Ward sorta clawed his way back.
You won some rounds like,
like later in the fight it seem like he had got that jab establish more and he
popped a couple of real good,
he was doing work but he got,
he was,
he was a 10,
eight round I think in the second,
second round.
I mean you could,
you could see a one point round for cove,
a 1.5 for coke won the fight though.
But I just,
I don't,
Oh shit.
It's crazy.
Crazy land and bombs.
Crazy fight.
But again,
it depends entirely on how you score fights too,
right?
I mean everybody has their own idea.
Kill him.
Again,
when you look at the numbers though,
Charlie's with numbers of like w significant punches favors Covello true,
but by,
by Joe,
uh,
you're number one fighters.
Mighty mouse number two is Anderson Silva.
Yeah,
that's my number one and number two because I judge him on what I see from him
right now.
And when I see like I understand that he's fighting smaller guys,
I understand they don't have as much power.
I understand that the margin of error is different.
However,
what I factor in is the greatness of movement and what I see in mighty mouse is
so pure efficiency.
I see crazy shit like when he got so Hutto in the clinch and he's throwing these
precision knees to the body that come with no wind up.
So who has no idea they're coming.
Mighty mouse puts it on
them.
I've seen the mighty mouse that saw Joseph Benevidez leaving his chin out there
and caught him with one punch and k owed him when the knock on him was that he
wasn't a one punch Stryker.
I saw him when he fought he,
okay.
Where he dominated.
He oakey for all five rounds and what a second to go.
She always catches him with an arm bar.
Yeah.
You know who we don't include them.
Pound for pound is not active enough.
Dominick Cruz.
But if you look at this record,
it's days.
He's great point,
but he doesn't,
he's not looking at it as a great,
I'll tell you what man,
him and Cody,
no love is going to be
quite interesting because Cody taxes,
anyone that goes to sleep,
he's my friend.
He's my favorite fighter at wait,
go see this.
And that's a good point because what we're talking about is about like guys who
are really good at certain things like Cody,
no love is way better at striking the,
what you're seeing right now is way better.
He's the chocolate Delta class.
He does creepy,
scary shit to people.
Like when he merch Thomas Almeda with that combination hike,
he's,
his stacking is like these guys make no mistake about it.
Benevidez and so who does he always,
trainers.
Joyce winning.
I'm not sure you're writing at all.
And I bet on,
I don't know about that.
You not catching man.
They do this every time it's been watching it.
We've been talking.
The thing is though is with,
uh,
with Dominick Cruz and Garbin.
Dominick Cruz isn't a knockout artist.
He's far from it.
So he might win 30 punches.
Garburate needs one in 25,
but we've never seen God Brant four and five rounds in.
Correct.
It's going to be interesting because he's a very explosive,
it's such a fun fight though,
but he's never been a guy that shows any sort of a slow down in his style get
man.
Some people are upset that he got it.
I love it.
Oh No,
it's great.
The only,
but personally I feel bad for it.
Yeah.
I feel bad for Tj went,
oh Tj,
here's fucking Linacre too.
Oh my God.
Here's Linacre the monster edge Liniger's is scary.
Yeah,
he's the scare.
Yes.
He's got so creepy power in his hands.
The motherfucking yeah.
Right.
And linear cause seems to have an iron chin too,
which is scary.
Fight scared.
Right.
He fights.
He said terrifying powerhouse.
See I thought John Dotson beat him really cause lot Linacre was gonna come and
forward nonstop at Dotson.
When that fight,
I'd have to go back and watch it again.
I remember seeing the decision thinking it was correct.
I'd have to go back and watch that again.
Who Do you think won this fight?
We weren't paying attention.
I've been talking to me showing up for think.
Join landed more strikes,
has persistent like clean strikes on his face.
That's where it looked like to me.
Might have and then you're going to have to pay his because Katie's throwing
but,
but Joey was just,
was
not getting her like it.
I like putting a little on on it and just done backer.
I like being in action.
I hear you man.
I don't really care who the horse and then the main event does,
does it?
Is anyone take it to Mellon?
Not You wrote and you know what I mean?
Cause they want to bend down to order pizza right here.
No,
that's my cheat.
Some players to know where we are.
Pizza players.
I was like,
what the fuck's up pizza player?
How do you guys do it over here?
I can answer the door.
How would know,
we could just say it's
Brian.
You could do it next door and just have him text you probably be out of here by
the time they come.
We have some protein bars.
You want a protein bar?
It's just as good as pizza.
You want to prompt him.
That would be nice to [inaudible] afterwards and you know what?
Fuck you got to do a set right?
Part of the agenda.
21 store.
I'm at the store at night.
Oh Shit,
motherfucking man.
He's always there putting together my new hour.
I abandoned my had to branch expression counts.
I'm talking about myself.
Is that okay?
Can I definitely get the gun?
Stop,
relax.
I'm over on this side.
I just can't believe you guys
get so greedy.
People talk about themselves.
I try to tell people some shit that's happening.
Two nights
he pushed the microwave.
Did you see that?
I've never thought about a special guy to you guys together.
You fight over each other so much.
You coming here,
you'd be putting on us.
That's right.
Now we're not about that.
We're not about guys about harmony.
Here's the difference in the Eddie Bravo night.
We get high when you guys aren't around.
When you guys are,
you guys are together.
You're not getting high.
Thank you.
Do you only 500 bucks?
You owe me 500 no,
I thought it was,
oh,
that's God bless choosing Smith's.
Joey,
I forgot who I was rooting for.
He won that fight.
Brian counselors aware and correct.
Let's see here.
Any booze volume please.
I shouldn't be booze.
Beautiful.
It's hard.
It's hard to tell.
It's like to road runner's fighting styles change.
Those riders killed rattlesnakes with their face.
You fuck you do not pay attention and joy.
Benzo Ludwig's technique.
His technique has changed and he looks amazing.
He looked very different in this fight than any of his other fights ever.
Totally different.
Not just from the little I saw.
Look you lost.
Nope.
Yeah,
I absolutely,
it wasn't paying enough.
He landed extension load plus I have marijuana in my system which impairs my
judgment.
Shall we crushed it.
I'm about three wines.
This fudge thing,
I'm just about the fun stuff is the shit.
It was nice,
friendly.
It's really good for you.
Good job.
Been back on Paleo.
Yeah,
I only got off of it cause I went on vacation for the holidays and I told you I
had the worst headaches.
Brothers.
I thought I was going to die.
I do the a abbreviated version where I'm,
I'll allow myself to have like some desserts and shit,
but I don't go fuck and full hog.
I just want to understand is what's bad for it now.
It doesn't feel good anymore,
but if like I make a grilled cheese sandwich for my kids.
God,
do you have a film?
I love a grilled cheese sandwich with butter to butter.
The bread I do.
I bought it.
The bread,
of course she bought her that kind of chatter.
Do you use,
do you use cheddar cheese?
Cheddar sharp cheddar cheese?
I'll put a tomato slice in the tube it out like that.
Joe Runs like the tomato slice slice really should be standard.
I agree.
Calfresh is a BLT get tomato and that's a cheese sandwich.
It really should be standard because it makes it juicy.
You got to use white bread because you're not eating anything nutritious.
Don't fucking give me weed or multigrain fucking me that all fashion wonder
bread.
White boy.
But I wouldn't be mad at you if you made me a grilled cheese sandwich with a
Zeke.
You'll bread but sprouts and Gouda.
Oh and long.
Raw milk could again heirloom tomatoes,
a little tomato soup on fuck.
Take grass fed butter on the outside of these feel better when you fucking fry.
He frightened a cast iron pan.
Correct.
She's not a criminal.
You have to have a food.
Not a bad person.
You're not doing this in a fucking George Foreman grill.
He used damn cast iron frying pan like a fucking pipe.
Do you make a grilled cheese or anything towards foreman chicken?
Fuck you gestured it really made a hundred chicken meals on a George Foreman
grill.
My life in college.
I would grill the fuck out of them.
Those things,
honestly,
it's a good way to do it.
You grill the top and the bottom at the same time.
He's like,
Shit.
The grill,
most of the people eat on George Foreman grills.
You not eating filet Mignon.
You getting shit cuts anyway cause you pour it.
Fuck.
That's true.
I've grilling like skirt steak and shit and my God and meanwhile Mexicans
figured out how to make skirt steak.
One of my favorite steaks,
the best.
They started fucking Marigny
skirt steak is a shit.
It really is.
You guys ever have a uh,
era in like your twenties where you're not living at home and you're fucking
broke his fucking,
you have $17 dollars and you got to somehow make that last a week and you're
like,
okay,
I got top Ramen,
I've go low loaf of bread,
macaroni and cheese.
I just call my daddy to call it that secretary.
I need some fucking money and my dad would go,
how much do you need?
Well,
I don't know,
$500 or 1,002 class news.
Cause
you guys how you guys were ultimately never be in my inner circle because you're
bored for sure.
Like,
okay,
$23 I had one of the market at all.
I got a calculator at the fuck.
I'm 22 years old and I'm like,
I gotta.
Okay.
Three boxes of macaroni and cheese,
a jar of peanut butter,
loaf of bread.
They get created milk,
four cans of tuna.
Damn,
I can take that.
That could take that for four days.
Burritos,
revival mode,
man.
I grew up with a shelf arrival when I was a kid.
It really was.
When I left my parents' house of Raman.
Raman was big,
what age?
Two top ramen.
But I was real pro at my brokest.
I was like 1920 was my brokest like those college.
Yeah,
well I was going to college,
but it was when I,
even when I say I'm going to college,
they should be
like an asterisk next to that statement,
please.
I was taking classes,
but I wasn't even ever thinking I was getting to get a job.
I just didn't want anybody thinking I was a loser and I'd run into people in my
town.
They'd be like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm taking a year off.
They'd be like,
Oh,
I'm fucking loser.
So after a year I'm like,
I can't keep feeling that every time I talked to somebody,
I got to go to school.
So I started going to college,
but it was barely paying attention and it was just,
I was paying more attention to like,
because that was at the time that I was considering doing standup comedy.
I hadn't done it yet.
Like and when I started doing it,
that's when I quit college,
but I was considering doing it so it was really more paying attention to people
and how weird we all are in this struggle between being child and being an adult
is this weird transitionary period where people are feeling their oats and
flexing their intellectual muscles in front of a teacher and trying to catch the
teacher what's wrong and trying to debate the teacher.
I was fascinated by that man.
I was fascinated by that because I was,
when I was fighting especially that was all when I was still competing.
I was always really,
really interested in conflict.
Any kind of conflict,
verbal conflicts,
physical conflict games and braced it.
You're saying I'm interested in it.
I'm curious as to what's going on here,
like why is this kid protesting what the teacher's saying?
Is he protesting because he's made a really solid assessment of the facts at
hand.
He finds a flaw in the logic or as you trying to get attention,
has he looked at it from,
if he's has step one through 10 to really verify what your thoughts are really.
Have you looked at one through 10 or did you go up to like three and you feel
your oats and you think you're smart as fuck and you dive in?
So I,
when I was more interested in when I was in college,
honestly it was just people interacting with each other.
My favorite moment from college had to do with his Puerto Rican girl that I was
trying to fuck.
Good for you.
And I was in the,
I was in the,
um,
that was in the lunch room with this girl.
This girl kept inviting me to go to these things with her.
What?
She was like these,
uh,
these,
these fucking retreats.
She's like me and my friends.
She was in my Italian trying to fuck some dude.
She was so hot.
I know that name.
She was so hot to conclude she was the inclusion.
Let me please tell me.
Let me tell the story.
She was thick and she was juicy and she had glasses and I knew she spoke
Spanish.
I couldn't wait to hear it.
And I was like,
it's just a matter of time as this girl's giving me all kinds of vibe.
Right.
I can our walls down.
She was like,
got to break the walls down.
We're going down in the Cape.
I would love if you'd come,
and I felt bad.
I didn't want,
I didn't want to tell her that it was going to fight in a tournament.
I started,
no,
no.
I was just super insecure about it.
I thought it was an idiot.
I thought I had brain damage was in college.
I was Jack you off in history now.
It probably not,
you know,
probably wouldn't,
it didn't sound even real to say,
you know,
like,
yeah,
you know,
I go home,
I'm going to go kick some dudes.
You know,
it just sounded like anyway,
I couldn't make it.
So she's like,
we do them all the time.
I would love to have you come again.
I would like,
I would love to come again.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I left dad.
It was like,
no,
no.
I was like pumped.
I was like,
damn,
we're in.
So then I went back to school after the tournament.
I'm sitting in the lunch room and ironically enough,
it was a Trump airplane.
It was one of those Trump airlines.
Trump,
Eric Trump.
No,
listen to me.
I was at the lunch room and we were about to eat and the Trump airline that day,
the fucking landing gear didn't come down,
but the Jed skid,
the jet skid into the runway and sparks and they put fucking flame retardant
foam over the runway.
It was crazy.
I went down,
I sat down with these kids was this Puerto Rican girl was so hot and all of her
friends,
and I sat down with them at lunch and I said,
did you guys hear about the jet that a,
that just crashed landed?
It had this run and they were like,
what happened?
And I said,
apparently the front landing gear didn't engage,
didn't lock down Trump airlines,
but everybody's fine.
And everybody,
nobody got hurt.
They go,
oh,
praise God.
Praise God.
I went,
Oh
and then I realized I was standing there over the table cause they're all going,
praise God.
Praise God Mike,
she and getting so
bad.
I sat down
with so much sadness but also happy because I love conflict,
right?
So I'm sitting here,
I'm like this little demon.
This is to have the tape
back then.
No diplomacy back then.
I'm fucking laser beam back then.
No,
then not a diplomat.
Keep calling.
You didn't even know me then.
This is when I was 19
I was 19 I was straight feral home.
I sat down at this table,
they're going like praise God wild.
My mother is a beautiful person and my Stepdad's a beautiful man.
I love them to death.
But they worked and when people work,
the kids are gone from whatever time to whatever they get out of school.
Shit.
Fucking wild.
Wild in the streets.
And that's how I grew up as was a latchkey kid from a divorced family and I grew
up hanging out with other kids and you develop these crazy and then I started
fighting.
So no juicy Puerto Rican ass for you.
So I was fighting so I had a very distorted version of things as it is.
So then I sat down and I said,
so this thing that you wanted me to do when you were asking me to go hang out
with your friends and the Cape and have like a big smile on my face,
I'm like,
that was about Jesus.
Right?
And they were like,
it's really important that you know Jesus.
I go,
you know Jesus.
Oh,
now she had this weird,
bizarre conversation.
She's like,
I,
Jesus is in my heart.
I go,
you did you.
Did he tell you that's his name?
Did you get to know him?
Like what are you talking about?
And then she starts talking about the Bible,
which Bible we're talking about.
We're talking about the old testament talking about the new testament.
And we had this creepy fucking Weirdo conversation when it was just such an,
you knew you were never going to be game over.
You're never seen those cheeks.
Oops.
I did.
It wasn't.
I was at at the time,
like for me,
I was as nice as I could have been while I was feral.
I'm sure she didn't talk to you after that.
No,
no.
I was done.
I was like,
okay.
I grew up around,
I was in Catholic school in the first grade.
I grew up around crazy religious people.
By the time I was like in,
you know,
my high school days and pass my high school days.
I was like,
I see what the fuck's going on.
Like you're crazy.
You're not talking to me in this.
So I was just confused.
Here's my question to everybody at the table.
She was so,
ah,
have you had my experience has colt like I was ready and really religious,
really religious girls.
Fuck.
Immediately in my,
in my dating history at the girl has talked about the warmth to the way they
approach.
Yes.
When they loved the Lord will be sucking your cock.
That guy behind him,
Matt motherfucking Hume,
that guy knows as much about Jay.
Yeah.
Might be the best.
He him and for us a hobby and there's like him,
Duke,
Roufus,
Surat for us a hobby.
There's a,
there's a few get bang for striking for sure,
but as far as like overall MMA coaches,
man,
it's tough to not give the nod to Matt.
Matt,
you more for us are my number one.
They're number one.
They're there.
It's like the pound for pound tongue and can really rotate them out and got like
GSP.
Obviously he,
he developed under the tutelage of for us a hobby,
but he would have developed under the tutelage of Matt Hume to maybe,
I don't know.
I think you would have,
if he could learn French
for Austin.
GSP were boys,
so they get his bond and connection is a big fighting for each other.
Now if you're Tim Elliot,
it's guns bombs away,
right?
What do you do?
It's bombs away.
You've got to go bombs away.
You think you just got to go balls to the wall.
What's in style?
Yeah,
almost.
Yeah.
I mean almost like the only way you didn't get to how technique.
This guy.
He's like,
who did it well and do the high level guy though.
It's lost.
It is like Geo beaten coming.
You know what I mean?
In a way.
Yeah,
you're right.
Most people thought Cummings was an,
you know and rightfully so.
He's mulling through everybody with this heel hook.
Hey Man,
Geo hang with that and he did her Daniel Exporters.
MMA is like Wednesday on the Mickey Mouse Club.
Wednesday is anything can happen day.
Oh yeah,
Wednesday that's an MMA is,
that's what MMA is as a sport.
MMA is,
anything can happen day.
Not at this weight class.
Disagree with that.
I disagree.
Disagree.
Those are little human being.
What do you mean anything can happen.
Can't happen because of the way.
Explain that.
He'd just said anything good happening inside disagreed because of the ways the
weight class.
What can't happen because of the weight guys can get k cause they're so wise
we'll get Kayo they do get care at all.
Like not maybe as often odds,
odds of statistics sizeist anything but anything can happen.
It can happen and I want butter.
Stock
out can happen.
And
the opposite end of the spectrum is the cad decision can happen.
Yes.
So
one,
can I just stop this before this fight and say this is my favorite thing to do
and my whole life,
the best thing in up this morning,
I woke up this morning,
crunk is fucked about it.
So stupid.
Fuck I fucking love.
We must watch this because he's ready.
And again,
here's the thing I'm saying I'm,
I've been singing this dude's praises forever.
I thought,
I don't think mighty mouse gets enough respect.
I don't think he gets the respect that he deserves that first phase of he's,
he's,
he said your name,
right?
So you say his name.
I love mighty mouse.
He's going to put,
this is what I think.
Forget about all the weight and all that stuff that you write.
You make some really good points.
But as far as an expression of martial arts talent,
that's the finest I've ever seen in my life.
I don't give a fuck what he ways as far as expression of martial arts talent,
that's the finest I've ever seen.
So if Tim Elliot can beat him,
which he absolutely can because it's Wednesday and Wednesdays,
anything can happen.
Not In the little boy's club.
Never know bro.
You most likely right?
Slapping people get injured.
Weird Shit happens.
Hands break,
knees,
pop backs go.
Mighty mouse does this for my mass.
Com Guy Zigs when he should exact changes it up.
Oh,
blocking plot.
Oh listen man.
Blocking.
But you never know man.
Damn.
I was doing some funky shit and loose.
You never know.
You never know dude.
Weird Shit happens.
The world is strange and moves so quickly.
It's because they're small.
Look at this Tim Elliot.
Good fucking shots from the bottom.
Who's good?
Scramble,
scramble.
Mighty mouse.
Barlow spinning.
Oh look at his left knee's got to get into play.
Can't do it just to try and go.
Can't do that.
You got some side controls.
Fuck yeah.
High level.
Cause if you just did that to Demetrius,
just get site control.
Top Position.
Your high level.
Yeah,
look at this all ready.
Let's go level right there.
Look,
he's on top
garden near holding onto the neg.
Good wrestlers base.
Mighty mouse is thrown those legs up,
but it's kind of look at the space and look at this.
Look at this base and balance.
This is why am is beautiful.
This is why MMA is beautiful.
Look at this Elliot with a good grip.
Oh,
nice knee to the head.
Elliot.
Look at this high level grappler.
Alien is highlights.
Don't get submitted.
Oh no,
he's passing.
Oh Yo dude.
No,
no,
he's not necessarily.
He's dancing.
It could be over.
Okay.
It could.
Oh,
if he doesn't shit.
Holy Shit.
Oh Shit.
The reason I was talking all that shit tell you I was trying to tell you,
it's over.
He's going to sleep.
It's over.
He's going to talk.
Talking all hundred percent
djs holding that thought.
Goddamn.
Demetrius Johnson,
he's got a little space.
There is a little space you see where he's using his time
and very deep,
but DJ
deep so quick means that he knows it takes a while sometimes feel like Phil
knows it takes a while.
He knows that's good.
Who knows
right
shots and saw amazing
holy Shit.
He's going to try
the neck.
He's going to try to go to the back and on top.
You know what?
Cast is a fight.
That's holy shit.
What if he gets him with the exact same ticket?
Raymark oh,
look at this.
He's got that are run under the neck.
Shafi float around with the same shit.
He might.
He looks like he's moving there.
He's moving there.
He's baiting him for the under hook on the left side.
Left under hook.
You're just sprawled out and you've got to hit her norm.
Dude.
You know about the amount of gold.
How dare you.
Oh,
he can get in with the exact same technique and he's punches that fucking right
arm under.
Let's see if he punches that right.
Aren't editor?
Nope.
He didn't even have it.
This Elliot back up.
Very nice.
Joe.
Say this with,
with the,
with the OSP.
John.
Joe,
give me,
Oh,
good fucking movement there.
Good movement.
Avoiding all those punches.
Even if he's tired.
That was good head movement.
Oh,
don't do this.
Fine,
man.
Fine.
No,
no dude.
Don't put hands on.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Less.
You're fucking around.
Wants to do.
Thank you.
Tired.
Tell me who's fucked around with this thing.
Elliot's fuck around and it's worth
playing.
Fuck,
you're right.
Let's not 12 now.
He just knocked mighty mouse.
Oh,
beautiful.
What is going on top of the world that this holds this round?
He's looking at the guy said anything can happen.
[inaudible]
is Wednesday on the Mickey Mouse Club.
Even in little boy's club.
Yep.
You run what's called
crazy
Johnson.
He's hurting here.
He just woke up to meters.
Just woke up and said what the fuck his feet.
But he's getting good teamed here.
He's gotta be real careful with that left arm.
This is Elliot Shit Man.
He's really good at closing the show for 10 seconds.
Oh,
he's pushed it off.
Good defray.
Nice cross to number one that Joe oil.
You got him let it.
Well,
it depends on how this plays out.
Sharepoint now never seen John in trouble.
Like,
oh you have in the gloves and fight.
He was in trouble and the Gustafson fight and you're not this bigger truck knock
the speaking side rocks.
No.
But Vito Belfort did catch him in an arm bar fully extended.
He said,
oh cool dude.
Here's the thing he didn't do.
He didn't have,
which was fucking substantial.
Second on your list,
I know you like John Jones.
We know this.
Okay.
Second is Connor mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse is probably like five for makers weight class.
He rose on your shit fro seven or eight last time we did never seven or duty
froze like a motherfucker fucker.
Hell yeah.
What those fucking counter labs.
Here's what I think about 10 pound for pound bricks weighs just like,
it's just like he's just waiting for him.
Who's going to take that shit?
He let me,
let me ask you if you guys agree with me.
This is how I feel about when you start talking about top 10 pound for pound.
My feeling is that it's a fun debate.
Correct.
I let the reality is you don't really know whether it's number one or number two
or number three cause there's an argument to the gross cyborg.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Yeah.
It's [inaudible] look at their stuff,
but you got to look at longevity.
You're looking at somebody who's beat up,
beat up silver did this man look at this.
Tim.
Tim Elliot went karate.
I look at this.
He went full side was so relaxed.
It's impressive.
Well,
he has dominated in several moments of that ranch.
He was doing it in the first round of jail before he was really,
that's race 10 tires.
Oh man,
man,
look at this.
Oh
Damn.
He stand in front of them while the more relaxed he can stay like that.
How you can wide shots and turn things into a grappling.
Ever relax was racist.
Get Out.
You see Henry pseudo like he's so relaxed.
That's,
what did he say?
He's lazy.
Yo.
Do people say that about me all the time I left.
I called Tyron Woodley.
Explosive.
What the fuck am I supposed to look at him?
Can you imagine when smooth,
smooth becomes racist?
Like duty smooth.
Like fuck yeah,
look at him
fucking smooth.
Fuck you.
I'm not smooth.
What?
I was born smooth.
You never know man.
He's his elbow.
You look at where his bicep is and the ear,
it's not going up.
It's going down.
You're not going to,
you might not,
but look at it with CEO's.
His like
Ula tore his bicep placement is his bicep is getting closer and closer to the
other.
It doesn't matter because he's on the opposite side.
He's in the wrong side,
but if a guy's really good at that empty half of physicians
can take a back like a motherfucker.
Oh Shit.
Mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse for technical shit.
This is defensively and I'll
say,
let's see
my mouse mighty mouse arm triangle.
That's a chopping block.
That's a chopping block,
right?
Elliot Simon ranked.
Where do you rank?
That's a good move right there.
Good
traps it position.
It keeps him from getting in that crucifix fucking striking crucifixions
because he needs his arm on the other side of the forearm.
The smashed him down with those and now let's see if he can pat.
Oh,
nice left arm was on the other side of his head.
That's all
he's looking for.
That salivary shit.
You can't put your arm on the other side because you're going to get fucked on
the right capital right there.
I'd go inverted arm bar right away
or something at that Nice,
neat play by Elliot.
He got that knee into position.
Is it high level grappler?
Man,
if he's super high level,
he's right there.
All the shit that's going on right here.
This is like real.
It's not about the submission,
it's about the wars.
Elliot beach.
Every champion in every weight class in his division,
it makes you a path of wars before the submission even comes up.
Not every so many wars go.
Oh,
it's not a good look at there's arms on the other side.
That's a crucifix.
It's going to get out of that.
But his left arms fuck.
He needs to get his left hand on the other side of his head right there.
Once he's there,
he's good.
He's getting easy to keep it over there,
but not that much over there.
Cause then you'd give up a Saturday one we gotta you gotta you gotta be the
master of,
he's going to go for the neck.
He's trying to turn her down bar from the half guard.
Oh Shit.
He's got a good camera.
It's a killer man.
That's,
you know,
that's one movie you really can get from the half card,
right?
I remember Matt Hughes Versus Joe Rigs.
It all depends on which camera you want.
If you want an inverted Kamora,
you have to be in an half guard.
If you want the regular Kamora,
you could pass me inside control,
but if you're going to do that inverted one,
you can't do it from side control.
You have to jump into half.
You have to hold him.
You hold,
you're holding him in half cock.
That's really interesting.
First Time I've ever thought about that.
No more challenge.
Japanese act the same thing.
Japanese neck dial in the exact same thing.
You want to stay there,
right?
You need to lose.
It locks
them down,
right at,
yeah.
Mayer and the inverted arm bar.
It's all about the angle.
So you know what?
I don't want to pass after all,
you know what?
We're going to stay in Africa and I don't even want to band and even if I was
passed,
if I went for the inverted bard inverted arm bar,
I would jump in a health card just to control the hips.
No,
he's not taking his back.
Dude.
This Elliot wins a position.
War II DJ cover the head kick when he had his back on top here.
Dj Show position.
It's one to one by.
Wow.
This is crazy.
Eliot on top again.
That's crazy.
The wrap up
high level with the grease and the sweat,
that makes it even harder to stay tight and stay controlled.
Shit to keep position and keep dominant position was and all that greets and
sweat and all that.
Vaseline all over your fucking eyes.
All over your back and all over my pants off.
Impose your will on me.
Impose your will on here.
Give me
some always talking about sex story
volume.
First time he's lost around you.
Don't shoot me and said,
I want to hear what he's saying.
The heart of it.
I wouldn't miss.
Dammit.
Fuck.
I want to hear man.
Human advice.
Damn.
Look at him.
Jumping around cardio that Dee did.
Sprints.
It's all about you guys talking about Randall's.
I did my rounds.
I did eight rounds.
I didn't nine rounds.
I did 10 rounds.
I train six rounds and it's about fucking sprints.
Are you doing your spray?
That's where the cardio is coming at the round.
You're sparring and Brown three.
That's not realistic.
It's the fucking springs up from South Portland.
Right?
Look at that.
If this guy wins,
Trump is president.
It's the biggest.
Is it their biggest upset in history?
Listen,
America's gun crazy.
Did you vote for Hillary Callin?
No,
not during this fight.
No fight.
Stop it.
Come back to it.
We'll come back to tell me the truth.
I begged
God.
Please,
please.
Dot.
Eddie please.
Andy.
I'm joking.
I'm messing with you.
Okay,
because she got to trap the arm son.
Oh,
he's covering his nose.
He's not allowed to do that.
Are you?
Oh my God.
That was a close.
Oh Shit.
Oh No.
Neck.
I did watch one.
Tough guys pick.
They're all juiciness,
takedown man.
Very nice.
Take Down Jesus Christ.
Look at this.
These guys are going to attorney and into a grappling match and he looks like
he's getting the better of these positions.
He's a honing yum grappling.
Juliet,
this is incredible.
Amazing.
Liquidus Elliot hangs on.
That's some Jujitsu and rolled him and Elliot stayed on top of the entire time.
This is incredible.
Look,
he's got the leg
desolate.
Temelia wrestling.
100% this is incredible.
Oh,
look at this shit.
he's getting lit up,
man.
He's getting lit up.
This is third round and kind of like,
God,
what the hell do I do here?
Damn.
He must have been tired.
And he says,
he's a champ.
He's so strong.
That's race.
Really good race old guys.
Oh look,
he's white as as he's got Simeon's.
I didn't say swim sprint.
I said regular sprints.
Well that's what I'm saying.
It's racism.
Work on Elliot.
Look.
Okay,
but look at this.
Dimitri is on top.
He's got that right arm trapped looking for that head out,
but not so not totally
capture fueled on math.
No,
really pat,
because he's white,
white trash people.
Stats are off trucks.
The stereotype.
White people get in the guard spouse.
I'm sick of it and I'm going to fucking stand up and right here on the Joe Rogan
experience,
I am not going to Sam for it.
Okay.
And I love Hillary.
We are not in this fight,
man.
People get shots.
What about that black people get past.
What about that political.
I didn't like either one of those cans,
right?
Coun Brian,
don't engage.
I'm watching a fight.
This is artist as your protocol.
You're a Cyborg.
Does Battlestar Galactica.
Hi Artists.
The CIA is not real.
I was playing.
I was playing squash to fight mighty mouse on top of your folks.
Round three of five terror.
Mighty mouse will get past that guard.
No,
he does.
Hell you drags them right back in strong.
It was wind earlier this round.
Now he's probably lose the race.
All look at this.
He keeps throwing those legs up,
man.
Elliot,
stop playing games.
The mighty mouse takes him back.
Rolls right back into half guard again.
Nice.
He might [inaudible] smart he is.
He's just thrown elbow.
Why not just do this shit.
Look at this.
Look at this garden with patch.
Elliott.
Got Some batteries with,
Dang.
He's very good off of his back.
I'll tell you that he's too,
because he can guard pass
mighty mouse for a second truck.
He did this before.
He just grabbed some up.
Ellie's my new training arm triangles,
his own arm traps.
Mighty mouse makes it somebody mouse can't do shit and mighty mouse was almost
kinda complaining.
Expect.
I'm going to let you loose so you can hit me.
It's great if they stand them back up because I can't stand me back up.
This is a beautiful position position too.
This is a good position,
man.
Yeah,
great position.
That's very interesting.
I haven't seen someone do that effectively in a world championship fight.
Oh,
he lost it,
man.
He lost it.
Let's see here.
Look at this.
That's a kid doesn't have an armed man.
That grease on the ball head.
Forget about how many steps ahead to the factor.
The bullheaded,
the grease
and the banner.
If he would've just had a nice fucking horrendous Shraub little fucking
Klieg.
Weda a little Brian Cowen,
he would have been fucked constantly.
Third round,
right?
Yes.
That's a great fight boys.
Delea Elliot's winning by the way.
Okay.
That's the nice crying.
Jesus Christ.
You gotta Rub it in my face.
It's two one.
This is a great fight.
Great.
But here's the,
here's a good thing.
A lot of people thought this is a wash.
They thought that Tim Elliot was out of his league,
this guy and a for submitted.
We're looking at a great fight.
So all bullshit aside.
We're joking around here and if you listen to anything you say tonight and you
think,
oh my God,
they're opinions are so fucked up,
we're were intoxicated and we're not serious.
So we need to know,
like if you looking at the actual fight itself,
if this is a great,
great fight,
and Tim Elliot deserves all the respect in,
the world should be ranked the top five.
Even when he loses his fight.
I'm not saying he's going to lose,
but if he does,
you have to rank them in the top five amazing performance.
Change your stance.
Now it's too late.
You can't change your stance in the middle of a fight.
It's amazing performance masses and pound per person or one anyway.
Well,
it's you are based on your,
what you've seen,
like the results,
John.
That's who you are and you got to add this in.
You have to add this in and in this fight he's getting dominated on in Granix
changes by 10 million by a guy who's not right.
The top 15 right.
You have to add that in.
If you want to be objective,
you have to add that in.
So then you'd have to look at him.
You'd have to like,
who are the other guys besides Dominick Cruz and Dominick Cruz.
Of course you really only doing it based on his past record,
the TJ victory and then the domination over your RHY favorite,
right?
Yeah.
You'd want them to enough.
You'd want to wait until Cody and him fight.
Damn.
But fourth round man.
Other than them.
Who?
Who else is in the running other than John Damn.
Look at Elliot.
The way he like,
he's holding his hands.
There's a help right there.
Who else?
He's doing some fucking Carolyn,
you know karate shit.
My guys,
Joe,
the highest white guys in MMA,
micro Brisbane,
the highest ranked white guys in the UFC.
I take the big guys,
we can't talk over each other.
White Guy,
Connor Mcgregor done and there was discussions.
Why is
my number one white guy in the US?
American white guy.
Well,
no one.
Why you fucked Russia?
That's a Russian
Cleveland.
He's Croatian.
He's from,
what's his name?
Steve.
Amy.
He's from Cleveland.
Born and raised.
Okay.
He was born there,
but what's does nanny?
We're all immigrants.
Hey,
you fucking drunk drunk.
You're racist.
White guy in the UFC.
He's not the highest weekend.
What are you talking about?
He's the heavyweight champ of the world.
They can kill all of them.
Look,
classically,
the heavyweight has always been the guy who could beat everybody below him.
That's what
Eddie Bravo please.
They don't have white weight classes because the small guys too fast for the big
guy.
They have weight class because the big guys too big for the small guy.
That's why the white guy that holds a belt in the UFC and answer me that
American American white cow.
Oh man,
he's got his back.
It's over son.
Oh Man.
Good fight.
The game's over
over.
Look,
he doesn't even have that load,
right hook.
God dammit.
He's my fucking hero.
He didn't even have the right hook and what a bad ass.
Oh my God.
Human will he see tick good knees to the shoulders in the batch I liked.
I liked how you guys went silent when you couldn't name another American white
guy with a belt.
Some saying,
hey listen,
Eddie Mexican.
No,
he's born in America.
He's Mexican.
Yes,
but he's American.
What is his last house?
What's his last name?
My Italian.
White as fuck.
My German shop shop.
German DJ on top.
Jay on top.
Crucifix.
It's on the wrong side of that head.
Goddamn crucifix.
Right arm.
It's in the wrong side of the head.
You can't have it on that sunlight ever.
It's always got a frame.
God dammit.
You got to have that frame.
Are we talking about Eddie?
Well,
he's good now.
What are we talking about?
Like,
if you could describe it,
if you could break down that position.
His left arm needs to be in front on,
on uh,
Demetrius Johnson's left shoulder on the left side of his neck.
Right.
You should come away.
Oh Shit.
I'm fucked up right now.
I'm sorry.
Wrong sign Elliot.
So it's like he's in the store.
You met,
right.
Okay.
Now we're going to know when I just said now it's totally different because
they're inside control.
How is this idea just trying to set up right there.
You know,
he's got old now.
His left arm was in a good spot.
Fights with his eyes.
Good spot.
If his left arm is on,
the other side of Demeter has had as a basketball,
that's where he,
right?
So he's got to keep it on this side of it was framing loss.
Always frame with that frame.
That's the frame that's didn't want to go on the other side like this.
Doris from,
do you ever hit that Doris from one guys pass into your side control?
Like,
do you ever let guys out of half guard inside control to catch that in this
situation?
It's super technical.
What I would do,
I can't just say,
I'm not asking right here,
but I'm asking do you guys,
do you know that Jeff Glover,
he loves that.
That position where
he's got his arms straight offending.
He's okay if he bends down.
Oh,
it doesn't look good.
It doesn't look good door shit.
He says to go arm bar.
I don't know.
She's got the president by power.
White power.
Say Chubb.
You're saying the Toby is based on all the Nazis they invented
guys.
This fucking fights crazy,
crazy.
Just cartwheeled kicked him.
It's crazy.
Callen like the Nazis.
Remember you did Joe.
Here's serious question.
Joe Sears.
Kellen like shoes.
Here's the kitchen for you.
That's a fight.
Politics.
Now here's one that no one talks about what they should.
Michael Bisbing pound for pound top thinking like the ics lost.
Do you think guys,
he's beat.
He's champ now.
He's one that he's dope.
Oh,
he's
in the UFC.
He's great,
but he's also been fighting a long time,
but he's also lost handedly where Anderson Silva is lost once.
Who's,
well,
he beat him up because he was manner.
He wouldn't have had a chance.
Who has Bisbing lost two?
Are you telling me that business is more winter Anderson Silva?
It doesn't,
but that that's champ right now.
Barometer.
It's not a bad barometer.
He's a champ right now.
He's got a makes a good point.
People deny it.
People deny it based on bad experiences that he had inside the octagon,
but his best experience inside the octagon was a Luke Rockhold fight,
which has got dance practice,
knocked him out,
knocked him out in one round.
He also fought Dan Henderson demolish the first fight couch account by chance
on,
and he got beat the challenge.
Pete,
Amy Boys,
PDS,
Callan and your boys the fence.
He just said the most brilliant thing ever.
He said,
who is the champ right now?
Can you imagine how hard it would be to be the channel right now at one fucking
Eddie fight?
This fight is going on with all,
he's the fucking champ right now.
Guys is fights going on.
It's really good and it's the last round.
It's good.
Oh
God damn.
Dude.
Elliott's a beast.
Are you kidding me?
This is incredible.
This is around five son and Elliot's on top.
That's crazy.
Mighty mouse.
Trying to roll to an armbar denied is that
it's kind of rooting for them because you're all white powered up.
You know what?
I was hoping I was wrong.
I only see color.
I don't see color.
I didn't even know who he's looking at.
He's got it took an army.
Is that Hitler?
Shit Bro.
Literally so unprejudiced I can't tell you new.
If you're in a red state,
you know me.
I don't care if no one's green or purple or orange.
I fucking don't care if they're fucking beige.
Beige on top or fucking or Magento.
Guys,
give us a couple minutes left.
I don't care.
Care abouts.
Watched the fun.
Bravo.
Three minutes left.
Let's watch this fight.
You just thought about that for you.
Give Him Malcolm,
Demetrius Dylan eight Denise decided control total shows on TV right now.
Right?
It doesn't look like he wants to watch Netflix.
Demetrius Demetrius has as dominated has controlled his him.
Elliot Elliot's been,
I don't think it's more of a control.
I think it's more of like he's just trying to be who he wants to be
caught it and oh my God,
we get to find out what the amount that turns you into a Gremlin was a matter of
I'm being fucking Tame,
right?
I want you don't release the birds released
once.
This fights over.
I think
to all of the,
keep my mouth shut.
I want to keep my mouth shut.
I think to all of us.
We don't want to go there.
It seems like all of us are talking over everybody.
We need to stop.
Just think I got what you're talking about.
Anything in the moment.
Let's just watch the last two and a half minutes each price.
Try that two and a half speed.
Simple up the fuck up.
I'm with Joe.
I'm a judge.
You guys on some other shit once he spouse when you should shut the fuck.
Got what the fuck is this is like Duran vs Aaron.
Bryce Shit.
Look at his passing on the left.
Hops over mighty mouse.
This is some Dak,
she gets that knee back and play again.
That's how this shit going on right here.
But fuck each other.
No,
they're trying to grapple each other.
It has nothing to do with uh,
feed production.
It has nothing to do with that.
It's going to be interesting cause from mighty mouse,
you know he was putting Elliot and danger more than Elliot was putting him in
danger.
Then that one time.
One time.
One time when this fight,
that's racist.
Come on man,
that's real burst.
That's a reverse racist is going forward again.
Eddie Bravo.
What's he doing wrong here?
Right?
Oh Shit.
He's not doing anything wrong right here.
Look how he's got control of that risk.
If he,
if he,
if he just really puts all his weight on his hand instead of the risk,
that's even better.
But he lost control.
He tried to switch hands it looks like,
like in that position,
when you pin that hand down,
a lot of people like to pin that wrist down.
It's better to fucking grab that hand because when you grab that hand and you
pin it down,
they can't move that arm at all.
It's a like a tremendous difference.
Although shit,
I can
look at that.
Elliot going towards the Camorra.
Oh Shit.
Look at those.
She's got some serious garage.
Happily.
Dude.
How about defined mighty masters?
Ponant they had to do the ultimate fighter.
He turns to her.
Oh,
look at this.
This incredible
look.
It's where's it gonna go?
It's gonna go full guard from here.
He's going to keep those under.
What is he going to do from,
oh,
he's going to go to full guard for bear.
Look,
he's got the feet up on the hips,
but he's letting another,
we'll see what he wants to.
Okay.
He changed everything.
Awesome.
Okay,
so now he's got,
okay.
These points,
there's so much gain from there.
I mean there's,
how hard are you going?
It's a whole different game from here.
Energy when you know there's only a minute left though.
This is all I get a few seconds for grueling fight.
They got to wonder.
This is so technical to keeping that top half position.
Damn.
It's going to go over with him with Aa.
Slash he would his hand if he would've went to Maya strategy.
Just straight up.
Forget the Camorra.
I forgot the arm bar.
Let's get the top half and then get,
get me free and then go to three winter.
Lose win is a win in that fight because now fans like,
Holy Shit,
this guy's legit.
100% agree.
Yeah,
he's a,
it's a win win for him.
You got to make a top five cheeto fingers.
Don't lose my number.
That's my new thing.
Positive.
Yeah,
me too.
I want to be positive too.
Now that's a stupid,
I'm a positive guy.
Joe.
Here's my number.
Let's stay friends.
Don't lose my friends.
Don't lose my number.
Let's stay friends to call me.
Call me.
I gotta be honest with you.
I was talking to a lot of shit in that fight and barely paying a hundred percent
control.
The control doc.
He was in trouble in the early rounds,
but he definitely controlled trotting off.
Well if I looked at moments where it looked like he was getting the better of
it,
I would give him the advantage.
But there was definitely a few moments.
It was a competitive fight.
No,
seriously,
whether he won or loss.
Okay.
Whoever,
whatever.
Was that the toughest challenge for Demetrius Johnson so far?
First champion or the second or third?
John Uranga.
Kraemer two.
Number three was the number one thing submitted them.
Who was number one was this number one.
Number one challenge.
Right?
Morocco put him in the worst dish rematch.
Rematch on this right away.
That'll be a fucking nice papers to one though.
In this fight.
Ultimately he won.
I still won.
He won the round.
He wins.
But it just like rocky one Monday at one 25 but rocky,
but we put on a 35.
There's no fights for him.
He needs to go up and fight.
Fight Cruise.
Cruise.
Yes.
And they fought before.
And one that you got to wonder,
you know,
at this stage in the guy's career,
how many,
um,
how many challenges does he have other than Elliot?
That'd be Xero.
Well,
he's got Benevidez now beat us beat.
So who'd I think he was trying to see the only be different the second time I
meet them again.
I'm doing it again.
We can't do sudo now because Benevidez just one.
So you'd have to have,
so who does,
cause that was a close file if your mind,
oh,
domination with Benevidez and so Huda pseudos in the mix.
His rice,
not the top.
He's going to improve.
It's two losses and I know,
I know,
but I know for a fact 100% Hutto he is improving on a daily basis.
Let's check this out is about it goes.
Yeah,
but
Bravo,
Eddie Bravo who won.
I'm going to say though the African e nine 46 right?
Callan mighty mouse,
of course.
100% I'm noncommittal still.
Of course.
He wasn't even a question.
Yeah,
no,
I'm not sure.
Price fine.
However,
I did not want to speak because I know I wasn't paying attention to at least 30%
of that fight
he won.
But Elliot
hell of a fight and Elliot is as tough as a human being gets.
I want to hear what Jon Anik asks him.
Was it your job?
Look how good he cranked.
This was going to ask you to just listen.
Listen,
sure.
The that belt nods off the victory of Johnson and I congratulate you
actually.
So good.
My sponsors.
Metro pcs.
Harmful sponsors.
Yeah.
Get your butt.
Look at,
look out.
Professionalists there's no waivers.
There's no stutters.
Watch
fighter.
Is that breast side down?
Muskrat chapter neutral.
I A man.
Well you certainly see that top position.
Almost 20 minutes.
You dominated with your grappling over the final pool.
Raul.
Raul one though.
Let's go back to it.
Medicaid fee and how close were you
dude?
That's fucking perfect.
He's so good.
He's like,
it's killer.
But does that mean what's that got your dog.
So it was tough.
First round when you know [inaudible] getting up siblings.
Get all over yourself.
I stayed like a champion.
Yeah,
me and him.
Enough fucking harsh doors.
Any gay teen writing?
What?
A champ.
Ngo.
Shit,
jail.
Put that.
What's next?
What's next number coming out?
Good man.
You back.
Great Jane.
Where's my coach is making your backers to invest close to the world and thank
you all majors.
You squad back at home.
James,
take shine.
You guys are amazing.
[inaudible]
Jon.
Anik is very smooth at this job.
Yeah,
he's a beast.
He's a pro.
He's like
no big deal.
Back to you.
No deal.
The same
shit.
What do you guys want to see what Tim Elliot says?
Listen to the crowd.
They love him.
I can.
You know I liked John and see what he's saying.
Look at this guy with the pool.
The fuck is that?
Is that this?
His Dad.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
okay.
I'm just trying to get back from Mexico.
That floats around.
How close do you think you would have realized that
even this,
why are you,
even though I was down in the winter time or now
Jesus Christ,
if it's a fight to the death,
you're 14 it's got,
it's ready to go.
He's not even tired.
He can go another five brown guys.
I think he's serious.
He's 100% serious.
I was on board till you said that.
I'm just,
I'm pretty sure
that's a very humble way of approaching it,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.
John Anik is a great fucking job man.
The play by play Guy John always would do overall rush.
Can you have,
there was a competition who's going to do a post fight interviews?
Uh,
paypal pay by play by play guys or color guys.
The play by play guys would crash the color guys when it comes to La,
like thinking on your goddamn fee play by play guys.
You need those guys because the post fight interviews,
it got all fucked up because of you because you were so good at,
you were the color guy.
Ed.
You could do the play by play shit.
You were just fucking slaying dragons.
So other promoters thought get the color guy to go in to the the cage and do the
post fire buddies.
And they all are terrible because that's the hardest thing they do that post
fight interviews.
You got 30 seconds to come up with a question that it's going to be on TV and
everyone,
it's gotta be the best question ever.
The play by play guys always going to crush the color of God.
Those dudes are professional broadcasters.
Try traffic cops,
boom and just lay down.
You just,
you just,
you know what I mean?
Like my guy for Ebi,
Tj Desantis Holy Shit.
When I,
I did,
uh,
I was like a guest commentator and he was a play by play guy.
I looked over at Tj,
I'm like,
uh,
you want to do fucking work for Ebi?
Holy Shit.
He was like Mike Goldberg.
You know what I mean?
She's just swaying TJ decisions.
Are you kidding?
He goes up there like a cool dude.
Coral Belle.
He's always been nice to me.
It just grab a,
Mike goes to a piece right now.
Let me ask you a couple of punches.
Guy.
He goes out of his way to do pieces in front of the camera.
He's so confident.
He's like putting shit together.
Let's do it on a piece of what?
This guy,
he's a podcast too,
dude,
are you kidding me?
That guy is fucking incredible.
Eilat shut up TJ like Tj.
We'll shout outs it podcast is,
Phil was shout outs.
Old wrestling coaches,
high school coaches from Brian.
He does God stories.
Brian,
shout out Hitler.
I feel like I had a good story that I told him.
Dude,
I will.
I appreciate that to feet.
Great by Jesus.
Jesus took that chair's as,
hey,
why you probably just got to
shout out.
Shout to my boy talk together.
I shot it as my boys Joe Rogan,
who has been getting such important people on his podcasts like Jordan B.
Peterson.
Is this one of the mainstream guys?
No,
no,
he's not
Eddie.
Of course he did.
I got to go to the comedy store.
The love you guys.
Some shit coming out.
Everybody listening to the show.
Eddie Bravo.
Bravo 10 on Instagram.
Yeah,
we've got to go.
Brian,
Y,
B r y and Callen.
Brendan,
come see me this weekend.
I'll call forehand nail like Eddie Bravo,
so he's known him for a fucking decade.
I don't even know my own student.
Pacific West [inaudible] is now free of the Fox and bill.
A book called
Jim Martinez Powell shot to Geo Ebi.
Best grappling fucking tournaments on the
UFC.
Fight pass unites here next week or a couple of days.
You crazy as fuck man.